this is Jocko podcast number 228 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening and also
joining us tonight once again is Dave
Burke good evening Dave good evening
so we only got through the first two
sections of the Marine Corps doctrinal
learning publication last time or the
doctrinal publication learning last time
so we're gonna finish it up today and I
must say that since we covered that
since I read this for the first time
I've been trying to pay attention to
things from a learning perspective
learning things and I've actually talked
to both of you
about squeezing your brains and we
mentioned it on the last podcast we kind
of breezed through it like I think I
just know yeah I've been talking to you
guys about squeezing if it's kind of
breeze through it didn't really talk
about what that actually means so I
wanted to I wanted to kind of do a
little discussion or dive into what does
I mean wasn't mean to squeeze your brain
cuz it's important it is so important to
put pressure the pressure put the
pressure on your brain on your thoughts
on how you're thinking because that
pressure creates heat and pressure in
your mind therefore creates energy it
creates ideas and that is how we learn
that is how we get smarter that is how
we get better from that pressure in its
highs back into something from the
discipline because freedom field manual
which is questioned everything right
question everything no matter where it's
coming from question your own ideas
question other people's ideas you got to
have that that mindset that kind of
rebellious mindset where you're always
going to push back against things and
I'm not talking
just being a contrary and where Dave
comes up with an idea and I say well
what about this I'm not talking about
that but I am talking about a
subconscious dialogue that's happening
where that's I would say my original
form of applying pressure to my mind was
sitting there saying is there a better
way to do that is there I'm um I'm not
saying I'm going to confront you but I'm
thinking myself is there a better way to
do that am I wrong about if I come up
with it am I wrong about this idea is
the tradition wrong is the way you know
the complain about oh this is how we all
would do it what do you constantly
saying well just because we do it that
way is that tradition wrong is that
standard wrong and in order to answer
those questions in order to answer those
questions it puts pressure on your brain
it puts pressure on your mind because
oftentimes the ideas that you're
questioning
the ideas that you're questioning the
standards that you're questioning the
tradition that you're questioning are
things that have been around for a while
they've survived some level of pressure
so to think that you're gonna come up
with some new way is it's a little bit
ridiculous
but at the same time you have to do it
you have to do it to free your mind
which I I used to post that on a pretty
regular before you mind but in order to
free your mind you actually have to add
weight you have to add you have to you
have to put a force on top of your mind
and your ideas in order to in order to
squeeze out results in order to free it
and when you do that then then that's
when you improve and I'm not talking
about the the kind of hey you know all
the constant self-improvement right I'm
not talking about sorry I'm actually
getting better I'm talking about actual
answers to call real answers to
questions actual improve
understanding of the world improved
understanding of the world so I've been
to you and I've been talking about this
game and but this is just kind of happen
and I think I think I sensed a light
switch flip or whatever you want to call
it
EF online you were coming up with sort
of the discussion point for the day and
so EF online is we got a bunch of people
coming on they're interacting with us
it's a zoom meeting which I think the
whole world is now familiar with zoom
meeting so we've expanded our online
presence and were really putting a lot
of time and effort behind EF online and
so you were and so what we've been
running these three times a week online
community brigade of people and so you
were you were you were kind of leading
the discussion on this particular one
and I think the question that spurned
you to squeeze your brain a little bit
was how do you adapt to a changing world
and you went through this story about
when you were the Marine Corps and when
you're a top gun instructor and what the
Marine Corps was doing at what top gun
was doing was preparing being prepared
to fight the mig-29 the mig-29 fulcrum
which is an aircraft that is correct me
if I'm wrong the fulcrum is not as good
as our aircraft and not as good as an
f-18 yeah that's right f-14 probably
than the f-14 so inside in the f-14 but
not not as good as an f-18 yep and
that's what you when you went to Top Gun
as a student that's what they were
telling you okay this is this is what
you need to be prepared to fight you
need mig-29 that's right an aircraft
that's not quite as good as yours not
quite as good as your f-18 that's what
they were telling you so then you leave
am I getting this right you leave Top
Gun school mm-hmm and when you come back
now to be the instructor the senior
instructor eventually the Russians had a
new aircraft yeah that's right
that was the the su-27 flank
which actually suicide note that happens
to be my favorite bird I like have you
ever seen that bird no it looks like God
it looks like a a cobra that's getting
ready to strike it's just an awesome
looking aircraft yeah and it was now
this aircraft is better than an f-18
yeah were you in for the f-14s at all
yes so I did a phase out at for teens so
the last f-14 class at Top Gun was
probably 2004 is when we phased him out
they probably flew a little bit in the
fleet but I was there as an instructor
during the last Tomcat class correct me
if I'm wrong in my mind the F the the
Tomcat has always been the muscle car of
the fighter jets is that yeah the iconic
muscle machine yeah for zooming I've got
a lot of power I can go fast yeah I'm
not gonna corner great right yeah so
more of a brute force machine really
fast really cool airplane but a little
bit dated by the time I was there Top
Gun so you're used to f-18 now the the
su-27 is now a real thing yeah and you
come back as an instructor and the
people the the the thing that you all
were preparing to fight was still the
mig-29 mm-hmm and you I guess looked at
this and said eh not a good plan there's
something better we should be prepared
to fight the worst case scenario for
which for us is the su-27 yeah
that's right and it wasn't even just the
worst case scenario it was just the
reality that this thing was being
proliferated so they're not the Russians
weren't just building it they were
selling it so was going other places too
so you could have well we're not gonna
go to war with the Russians like okay
maybe not maybe we're not gonna go to
war through Russia's but this airplane
is gonna find itself in places they
wouldn't even know and if we showed up
to meet that thing and we were
unprepared we're gonna get rolled and
that was a big deal we're gonna get
rolled so you saw this new world
basically and you adapted to the new
threat you adapted to this new reality
and that was the lesson that you were
trying to share on EF online which was
hey when you get a new reality which by
the way this is all in reference to
kovat 19 what's the new reality and
we've got
every different spectrum of business on
there so it means different things to
different people and the bottom line is
the lesson was you get ahead of the new
reality you don't wait for it you get
ahead of it and when we got off the call
or whatever and I and I talked to you
about it and I said some like hey that
was a that was a solid lesson like did
you squeeze your brain to get that out
and you said something like yeah I did I
squeezed my brain I thought about you
know what is this situation and how can
I explain it better and when you do that
you understand better right like you
Dave Burke when you when you when you
put that thread out there and you you
you you carried us through that story
you understood things better and that's
why when I get all excited about
understanding the world in a better way
that's an example of how even you this
is something that you know it's
something that you actually did as a
human being and yet until you recognized
it from that other perspective until you
scream you squeeze your brain and put
pressure on your brain you don't get the
benefit of it the real benefit the next
level of benefit and then when you start
to tie these threads to other things
other things that only don't always
appear to be related like covet 19 and
make 29s but they are related then you
win so every time you put pressure on
your mind you force yourself to think
better and get better and this happened
to me the other day again and it happens
to me I'll be on sorry that actually
happens to me a decent amount because
I'm always yeah well again I'm always
trying to put that pressure on there I'm
always squeezing it and it was another
EF online scenario and what's good about
EF online is look when people send me a
question over social media it's cool and
we try and answer the question but you
can get
texture around it on EF online you're
getting the context the person there in
this case particular case was a guy
named Ben and he was talking about being
on the path and at the time and you know
it was something along these lines he's
been furloughed he's not in charge of
anyone right now he's stuck at home
they'd be a good time to get in shape
but he's having trouble doing it right
so I went down the path of again because
the way this story was unfolding from
him he's normally at work he's normally
in charge of people so we're talking
about it from a leadership perspective
and I said something like hey you are
not in charge of anyone else right now
but you're your own CEO which is
something we hear all the time right
you're your own CEO you're your own
Supreme Commander you're your own
general and he got it he said thanks and
that was cool then I kept thinking about
it because there was some like thing in
my brain where it makes sense but it's
not that easy it's actually not that
easy because here's the deal you are
your own general of your life and you're
gonna come up with a plan you're gonna
make decisions you're gonna give orders
right that's what's gonna happen here's
the part that I was kind of missing is
that yes
you're your own general you're you're
your own commander on the battlefield
but you are also the soldiers you are
also the troops you are and we actually
know factually that troops don't just
blindly follow orders that doesn't
happen we hey look we would like that to
be happening right it would well let me
rephrase that that's the scenario that
people think would be totally ideal that
I bark orders and everyone listens to me
but we know we know that that doesn't
work it doesn't work in the military it
doesn't work in business it doesn't work
with your kids
it doesn't work you have to get people
to a certain point they have to be
trained they have to be educated they
have to be disciplined they have to know
why they're doing what
they're doing and if you don't explain
these things to them then they're not
gonna do what they supposed to do right
they're not gonna do what they're
supposed to do if you're if you don't
build that relationship if you don't
have that unifying mission it's not
gonna work so if you're too close to
your feelings all kinds of parallel if
you're too close to your feelings right
if you're reacting to your feelings like
oh I really don't feel like doing this
then your feelings gonna start to drive
the way you act and we don't necessarily
want that all the time just like a
leader if a leader is too close to his
troops and the troops are pushing back
he says oh we don't want to do that oh
okay you guys don't feel okay you see
what I'm saying it's like a perfect it's
a perfect parallel at the same time if
you just bark orders at your troops and
they don't know why they're doing what
they're doing then they're not gonna
commit to doing it in any meaningful way
and just like troops you know if I barf
if gave if you're a grunt and I bark
orders at you you go yeah yes sir you go
do it I do that to you the next day you
go do it I do that to you the next day
all of a sudden you're not you're
lagging I do that you for a month
you're not invested anymore same thing
so so when you say to yourself I'm just
gonna get up I'm gonna get up and do it
that's cool it might work for a day it
might work for two days it might work
for three days and sometimes I
absolutely use that use that type of
leadership with myself where I'm you
know hey look there's no time to debate
right now you need to get up and go do
your workout but if you try and make
that the way that the only way that
you're leading yourself functionally
over time it's gonna fall short if you
push your troops too hard they're gonna
break right you can actually push
yourself so hard that you you you break
you can over train if you're too easy on
your troops you can then soft same thing
with what the way you happens with
yourself the better you try this is an
important one
the better you train your troops the
better they respond so once my troops
are used to hey this is how I do it this
is why I do it once they're used to that
they respond better they know what it is
I want from them they want to give me
that response just like when you follow
a routine every day and you know what
you're supposed to do and your troop
your mental soldiers know what they're
supposed to do they start to respond
better you know when you realize when
your mental troops know that hey doggles
gonna work out it's gonna happen and we
could either stand around and
procrastinate or we could just suck it
up and go get it done they go if you
know what hey this is going that way so
the better you train your mental troops
the better you're going to get a
response from them the better the better
you take care of your mental troops the
more they're gonna take care of you as
long as you don't coddle them as long as
you don't spoil them because once again
they're gonna be soft and they're gonna
be worthless so you are leading yourself
that's the thing you are leading
yourself you are in charge but you are
also the troops that have to do the work
and if you understand it that way then
you can actually start to pay attention
between the relationship that you have
with you as the leader and you as the
troops and the connection between where
you are and where it is you want to go
because the general might want to secure
a beachhead
but that's meaningless without the
troops taking action and making and
actually making it happen
so the ideas and plans of the generals
have to be executed by the chain of
command and they they might do it out of
fear for a minute but they're not gonna
do it for a long period of time they
will do it out of Honor they will do it
out of pride they will do it if they
understand the long term goal they will
do it if the goal of the
general is aligned with the goals of the
troops if they're not aligned we're not
gonna get what we want so whether you're
talking about the the chain of command
inside your own head or the chain of
command in the military of the chain of
command a business leadership is
leadership is leadership and we we
cannot we cannot lead if we don't learn
and we can't learn if we don't put
pressure on our minds to make them
figure things out learning and with that
let's go back to the book you ever seen
the movie Goodfellas yes so there's a
scene
yep I have so you know the kids so
there's a scene where was Joe Pesci
I think his girl just came from the
airport smuggled some diamonds mm-hmm in
her hair it's a long okay sure and she's
like okay let's get these diamonds on
and she's doing this and they're all
falling out and she's like yep that's it
you know right and they're like he's
like hey you sure you don't cut any but
there got to be more in there there has
to be she's like this is a this is it
so she he's like oh there's no and he
essentially squeezes her little hairdo
shuffles of end a few more diamonds come
out right you do a little bit of a
breath and remember how we were talking
about this before where you're
essentially when you told me about the
brain squeeze was a essentially a
rebuttal to the idea that aught it's
just not coming to me hey it's not it's
time you know it'll come in time or not
at all right like it then it's not meant
to be almost kind of thing right that
was your rebuttal cuz you thought that
that's essentially what I was saying I
wasn't saying that but that's what you
thought I was saying and and that makes
sense especially when you go but not
especially but when you go back to the
Goodfellas analogy where you know in her
mind yeah hey that's it that's all we
got you know what I'm gonna do rip and
shave my head
oh right that's all I got you know and
so bad she was like oh man we're gonna
do a little brain squeeze we're gonna
get a few more diamonds how do you
that's the deal
that's sensible yes sir you get one
credit for today I think I understand
now black already yeah well you talked
to me about that my figures you're
talking about making videos which is
your creative pursuit on the earth shirk
wonderful and you were telling me that
sometimes yeah you know this this idea
is a little bit of an idea whatever and
then it fades and you forget about it or
you don't execute on it and I was
telling you that in fact the little
ideas just aren't gonna grow to be
outstanding without some pressure on
them now putting a little squeeze on
you're not gonna get those diamonds out
you know as they're gonna hang out and
you know I guess maybe part of me and
when I'm kind of thinking back on that
whole scenario or a scenario scenarios
like it where I'm kind of like or I was
with the philosophy of like whoa hey
look if there's some diamonds in there
haints they're gonna come out you know
let's let them come out naturally so
they can kind of you know through their
own volition kind of manifest themselves
kind of thing you know and I think after
thinking about it it's like man I don't
know if that's the best way I'm
reviewing my entire life right now
in my head all of us as fast as I can
and I'm gonna say that I think if I
didn't put pressure on my head I would
be zero I would be zero my score would
be zero there will be zero diamonds on
the table zero not that I'm saying I got
diamonds on the table but at least
there's some pieces of coal come out and
they can they can whenever we can
scratch some black marks on a on a page
or whatever like at least it's something
it's bet it's not nothing yes right yes
so we're gonna have to do it but this
perspective of learning and the one of
the one of the things that I realized
that I never thought about before when
they talk about learning as we covered
on the last podcast they're taught
they're talking about if I see the enemy
do something that was effective I
learned
we I've never thought about learning
from that perspective before in my life
so this is a new development but now I
just took that idea and started thinking
about how there's a lot of things I've
learned along the way and I was trying
to pull the thread and see what the
source of that was and a lot of it
boiled back down to like asking
questions of everything that I see and
again I'm not talking about being a
contrarian because contrarians they have
their today of their time in place and
I'm sure sometimes I might be a little
bit actually I don't actually don't
think that I don't think I'm a contrary
I think I will if there's an idea that
is contrary to what someone is saying
and I would like to explore whether it's
right or not I will bring it up all day
long but I won't bring up an idea just
to kind of be differ the sake of doing
it yeah I've worked for people like that
yeah it's like part of their personality
I work from one in particular and it was
just super annoying I you know and I
just have to be like mm-hmm especially
because he was a senior guy and so his
little contrary and statements would
would send people in directions that I
wished we were not going cuz I knew that
they were not gonna prove they weren't
gonna provide any fruit on the other
side
definitely no diamond from the the brain
squeeze also it does like secondary
stuff to where let's say you're trying
to squeeze your brain right I need this
idea to kind of fulfill this last
element of this comprehensive idea that
I want to put out mm-hmm and he just
want a little element and I'm squeezing
my brain right no diamonds yet but other
stuff is coming out like Aladdin maybe
some you know maybe a Ruby over here or
what do you call those blue ones the
Sapphire whatever maybe over there we
are the I don't need that right now
but that came out maybe I'll save that
one for later maybe maybe those will be
part of a future idea I'm saying oh so
boom you got all these jewels
essentially and then finally let's say
the time it doesn't come up let's say it
straight up doesn't come out you know
you got all those rubies and stuff if
you didn't do that brain squeeze you
would a have no diamond anyway without
those other jewels you see I'm saying
yeah I'm taking a like a sub car
just kind of note to myself or or I'm
putting myself on subconscious notice
because like you and I are sitting here
just throwing around that we're just
producing that's so just not true you
know but I it's a metaphor yes sir
producing an idea which may or may not
have value but the thing is it doesn't
exist unless you put some pressure on
your on your mind yeah and it's so you
just like working out right you're not
gonna get strong if you don't put some
pressure on you you're you're not gonna
get better jiu-jitsu unless you get some
pressure put on you doesn't happen so
you have to put pressure on your mind
the thing is you can so easily go
through life right now without putting
any pressure on your mind at all yeah
you can go through life right now and I
guess what I'm talking about my little
you can be a 36 year old a 42 year old a
19 year old and put no pressure on your
brain and just resort to the modules of
knowledge that you have and if they
don't fit that well it's cool just just
you know put some spackle over it and
call it good Dave
relatively quiet over the dude I'm
listening man that's uh that was pretty
legit and yeah squeezing your brain you
and I talked about that for a while and
that that particular case was kind of
cool because I didn't know that I was
gonna be leading that you know taking
point on the initial conversation but a
couple days prior after we talked about
it I started thinking about it and so
laughs calm is okay man can you can you
take lead on the EF online on whens I'm
like absolutely I've already been
thinking about it which was also a
really cool thing that I didn't think
about when we were talking about this
squeezing of brandy it makes you feel
more prepared about things in life in
general not that I was trying to produce
I wasn't thinking to produce something
for the for the EF online module that
wasn't why I did it and then when he
asked me I'm like yes absolutely and
then I spent more time creating that you
know but I'd already been thinking about
things to make the connection because
we've been doing that so much and the
world has been
changing for a lot of people God and I
just started spending some time
squeezing my brain not to produce
something that was for a deliverable or
a client request that wasn't about the
outcome it was about doing it and is
pretty interesting how those two aligned
and is like hey can you do this I'm like
actually no factor cuz I've been
thinking about it so you've been getting
kind of broad questions from clients
about how do we adapt to what's
happening and you started squeezing your
brain to figure out yeah way to explain
that that would be very clear and and
would make people connect the process of
doing it to a story which makes it
easier to understand well the stories
are important but as we've have we've as
we've been continuing to answer
questions you have to find more ways to
convey that message some resonate and
some don't as well and sometimes what
would going on a month ago is actually a
little bit different what's going on now
so I wanted to think of more effective
ways to be able to communicate things
for people to listen to and do something
about and that was what the squeezing of
the brain was initially for me is I have
to be better at explaining what's what I
think is going on so people can do a
better job dealing with it and if I just
kind of go it the same way I've done it
that little roll with next type guy like
I'll just go back to module because like
well module B doesn't always work for
everybody it's made it makes me smarter
like you described but it also makes me
more effective for those people so I was
just thinking about it in those terms
and then he's like hey man can you do
this Mike yeah I've been thinking about
this a lot lately and of course we've
been talking about it and I've been
thinking about it a lot in general in a
whole bunch of different ways and it
isn't always just like what can I do to
convey for other people this is actually
more about me and just getting better at
thinking about things and getting better
at making decisions and getting better
at solving problems because I actually
am not as good as I need to be on that
not even close
yeah the idea that what you're talking
about is learning that's what we're
talking about we're talking about
learning and learning can be a passive
thing where you're you're waiting for
someone to show you the way or it can be
something that you're proactively
engaged your brain
yeah and I think this book I can't
remember exactly this idea of this
learning being continuous process the
biggest weight against me personally
this applied ship a lot of folks
continue to do this is looking back and
be like I have done pretty pretty well
for myself you know I'm at this stage in
my life I've accomplished these things
and that's the biggest weight against
continuing to do this and this is what
keeps me from getting complacent is what
keeps me from getting comfortable what
I've already done and think we laughed
about it the other day I was telling you
like I actually forgot I was in the
Marine Corps for 23 years because I'm so
focused I'm trying to figure out a whole
bunch of other things and I'm not good
enough that yet and it's actually
healthy to not rest on the laurels of
whatever I did in the past because that
actually isn't enough to keep me moving
forward and if this actually is
continuously want to do this you have to
do this thing all the time all the time
don't you find though reverse kind of
over overlaying new information on what
happened in the past the speaking of EF
online I did that today I was talking
about Mike Cirelli it's it's we covered
up when Mike's role goes on the podcast
the first thing I did when Mike's really
checked in it's asking a bruiser he's
checking in late is I gave him a
counseling a written counseling and I I
was explaining why I did it
and I actually like back then whatever
it was 15 years ago or something like
that 15 years ago when I met him if you
would have said why did you do that
you know I said cuz he's checking and he
needs to be squared away or something
like that I would have given this but if
you would have actually squeezed my
brain at the time and said wait a second
no Jocko year you're in a leadership
position you take action because for a
reason
tell me why you actually why did you
actually decide of everyone that's in
task unit bruiser you got this new guy
coming in why is it him that you've
decided at this point in time that you
want to give him a written counseling
the minute he checks in and I I was
thinking about it and I was squeezing my
print and I realized a couple things you
know number one he was coming from a
tasking that just self
and I didn't want any that drama number
two I wanted him to know that I was
serious about what we do and the last
one the one that I had to squeeze my
brain to get to is I didn't know Mike
and we were gonna deploy in a few months
and I needed to know who this guy was
I knew he was a prior marine I knew
who's a prior recon I knew whose prior
sniper and I but I didn't know him and
so by me taking this young officer date
the minute I meet him and say yeah I
come talk to me and I hand him a
counseling sheet and when it said was
something along lines of hey there's no
drama and tasking a bruiser
so don't bring any drama to tasking a
bruiser in Mike was like Roger that and
he designed it and that moment when I
saw his reaction is what this whole
thing was really about it was really
just a test to see who am I getting is
this guy have a big ego is this guy have
a bad attitude is this guy think he's
smarter than everybody else is he when I
say hey I want you to sign this
counseling to say this is ridiculous why
should I be or is he you know roll his
eyes at me or is he gonna you know huff
and puff or whatever is his ego gonna
come out that's that's the purpose and I
can now look back and see hey totally
that that's that's that's one of the
reasons why I did it
and that all came from that all came
from the fact that I was talking to this
other woman on EF online and talking
about the Willy Wonka freaking example
of how you test somebody the N don't we
ever seen the movie Willy Wonka echo
Charles the original no sir I'm not
that's pathetic the end of the original
Willy Wonka he goes off berserk and
tries to get the person to change his
mind or to reveal himself as either
being a thief and untrustworthy or being
trustworthy so I had explained that too
and so now I could see clearly why I'm
doing this so even though you might say
I forget about being the Marine Corps
and I get what you're saying like it's a
it's a yeah I get what you're saying
what but the reality is you take what
you take this new thing that this new
thing that came out of your brain and
you overlay it on the past you go oh
this makes tone
sense now oh I totally see why I would
do that and so it's a little reverse
engineering it's actually a lot of
reverse engineering but it also reveals
hey where did I make mistakes what did I
do wrong why did i do why did I act this
way when I shouldn't have if you want to
take the things that you've learned and
turn them into a little bit of wisdom
that might be helpful for you or your
kids or the people around you
you have to do what you just described
it's and and that's been the part that
I've been wrestling with is I look back
and think I did a lot of things but I
didn't think about why I was doing them
nearly enough to be as wise or
articulate as I should be to look back
and so I didn't taking those lessons now
that was just one of a million different
things I could think of and think what
were we really doing when we were doing
that and if you don't do that all it is
is an experience and the thing that
matters the most is what you took from
that not just for you but for the people
around you if you want to create some
wisdom from that you have to do what you
just described and that was one of a
million more things I have to do and
that's part of the reason why I was so
fun as I took this cool story from Top
Gun I'm like you know what I didn't
really think about why we're doing
there's a big thing while we were doing
it and I didn't really think about it
there is no way I would have thought
could what we were doing now somehow be
helpful somewhere else down the line
other than rebased lining top gun
training for this next aircraft that's
what I thought we were doing and that's
not what we were doing there was so much
more going on there and the squeezing of
my brain is trying to create a much
larger context for all these things that
I did in those 23 years that I look back
and I'm like dude if you want this to be
useful you have to think about it a lot
more yeah and it's not easy that when
you see the patterns the pattern
recognition over time you go yeah that's
what I was doing there yep that's it and
for me that a lot of that stemmed from
jiu-jitsu because yeah that's when I
started connecting the dots of oh you
don't want to attack an area that's
reinforced in on the battlefield in
jiu-jitsu or as a leader you don't want
to attack in air okay I got that oh you
need to maneuver you need to you need to
be able to move right think about that
just think about that concept in
jiu-jitsu when you get when you get
immobilized you are on the way to defeat
the minute that you can no longer move
you are on your way to defeat well on
the battlefield if you can't maneuver
anymore if you dig in and you can't move
you're on your way to defeat and
mentally if you close your mind and you
stop thinking and seeing other
perspectives and keeping an open mind
you are on your way to defeat so when
you start taking these and seeing them
in other areas it opens your mind up it
frees your mind in so many different
ways and that is learning that's what it
is all right little preamble so chapter
3 the learning environment it is
necessary for us to learn from others
mistakes you will not live long enough
to make them all yourself that's uh
Admiral rickover next one our knowledge
of circumstances has increased but our
uncertainty instead of having diminished
has only increased the reason of this is
that we do not gain all our experience
at once but by degrees so our
determinations continue to be assailed
incessantly by fresh experience and the
mind if we may use the expression must
always be under arms so new things are
gonna come about and you gotta be he's
using he's using kind of a different
metaphor I'm saying keep your mind open
he's like you gotta be ready we read it
ready to adapt yeah keep your mind under
pressure yeah yeah under pressure
exactly next here victory does not
necessarily go to those who have the
largest or most modern forces but to
those who are able to recognize the need
to adapt generate intelligent decisions
and execute them more quickly than their
enemy victory does not go to the person
who's the biggest and strongest echo yes
sir
goes the person who can adapt who can
make intelligent decisions and execute
them quickly
skipping ahead in the progress in the
progression of learning training should
provide Marines with an opposing will to
practice against through wrap through
repetitions in a training environment
Marines loaned out think adversaries and
overcome friction prior to encountering
these factors during real world
operations therefore Marines must
integrate lessons learned from current
and previous conflicts to adapt their
learning environments methods
assessments and feedback to reflect
evolving threats got a lot got a lot of
questions about this one right a lot of
questions of how do I get my mind ready
to do this like it's easy to sit here
and talk about it hey you want to be
adaptable hey you want to be able to
detach you want to be able to handle
pressure how do I actually do that oh
you got to put yourself in those
environments you've got to go against a
an opposing will in order to practice
sparring that is jiu-jitsu yes you know
what what is up very well for you it
might not be underrated because you seem
to know the importance of it or the
value but roleplay right like
role-playing scenarios or whatever yes
we do 100% see the value right but that
role-playing goes deep though because
and I I don't want to say I learned it
for me but you really you brought it to
light the importance and how of how good
it works but just how easy it is to do
so I think like okay so I'll so my kid
he's three and I'm gonna say hey you
don't like wine or whatever and don't be
like what or don't be what I say you say
you stand up straight and say yes sir
when I say your name you say yes sir I
don't require them to do that but it was
like a practice didn't have a certain
attitude so I'm like I say if I say your
name you say yes sir don't say what
don't say like that I said when I say
your name say yes sir and he's like okay
you know no role player like okay so
next time it happens I expect you to do
that kind of thing but I said oh no
we're gonna go through it let's practice
so I do it like two times took like what
30 seconds
it's not even 30 seconds now every
single time but I gotta say it in a
certain tone but still it's in his head
now you know cuz he's sort of been there
seems in rather than just some idea on a
paper or out of my mouth or whatever
yeah the value of roleplay is equivalent
to the value of rolling in jiu-jitsu
yes bar that's essentially what sparring
is wouldn't with additional motivations
of course but yeah I mean that's really
the story that you let in with is what
we were talking about earlier z--
everything we did at Top Gun was role
play because nothing was live you're not
fighting against a real enemy and our
problem is who were role playing against
somebody who wasn't good enough to make
us better and like hey I'm doing
everything right I'm winning and and
that meant I was gonna but the role play
the other person and that role play
wasn't wasn't role playing a hard enough
situation for us to for us to be
effective it and just like jiu-jitsu you
wanna roleplay against ya the best
possible opponent you can look can you
ever do that yes you can if all you do
is just get smoked and I bet you guys at
Top Gun as instructors had to back off
all the time all the time and we we had
dials we did we dialed by design we knew
what we were doing but ultimately there
has to be some place where the roleplay
isn't designed just so you can win the
role play is design so you can be
challenged correctly and you know we're
gonna talk about adaptation but the more
effective your counterpart is the more
you have to adapt the less effective
they are the more you can just stick to
your plan and you win and that's a
really bad lesson it's like I just keep
the one I'm doing I'm gonna be okay yeah
the more effective your opponent is the
more pressure you put on your brain
that's right and the better results
you're gonna guess the moral are gonna
shake out of your hair is there learning
environments there's not a single
correct design for creating the ideal
learning environment because each
learning objective marine team and
condition will differ
therefore Marines modify learning
environment to most effectively meet
their the learners needs and reflect the
conditions that they expect to encounter
effective learning requires environments
that foster flexibility of thought
reasoning and the creation of the
potential solutions to the problems and
encourages Marines to explore
alternative courses of action
I had to highlight that part
because effective learning requires
environments that foster flexibility of
thought reasoning and the creation of
potential sisters so that so if a fat
Top Gun what you did was said okay bill
on this run you're gonna go up you're
gonna do this maneuver of this maneuver
this maneuver of this maneuver this
maneuver this maneuver and you're gonna
do them in this required timeline like
you could create some false pressure
with the required time line they would
get good at doing this maneuver this
maneuver in this maneuver and then as
soon as a real thing happened and they
got the wrench thrown into it or you
came out of it you just uh Niall ate
them same thing with jiu-jitsu or the
old school vittatus yes right that cut
does in whatever traditional martial
arts here's the move you know there's a
downward thrusting blow from your
opponent you do the X block and then
whatever you do these coordinated moves
which is what made those type of martial
arts when UFC started or when they were
doing nhb in in Brazil or Valley tudo in
Brazil Brazil then the traditional
martial arts that had been not learning
in this way not learning for flexibility
of thought and reasoning in the creation
of potential and what they didn't train
for that they trained for a downward
frosting whatever and when they got an
opera cut or a leg kick that they didn't
know how to work against they were dead
in the water
mm-hmm same thing with when I was
training the seals that's how we trained
the seals we're not training hey here's
the here's the here's the next maneuver
that you're gonna do is called a a
Center peal good now walk down the
ravine and when the whistle blows you
guys do a center field actually that's
how we start off right that's the
beginning and I'm sure there's maneuvers
you guys taught at Otacon hey here's the
maneuver here's what you do yes but
eventually you got to figure out what's
maneuver you're gonna do when you're
gonna do it how long are you gonna do it
for what's your next maneuver gonna be
yeah and what little changes are gonna
make to that maneuver in real-time
because it's not going to be the rote
application of that maneuver you learned
it's gonna be a variation of that
try and expand people's brains an
effective learning in back to the book
an effective learning environment
enables Marines to clearly understand
the intended warfighting doctrine
concepts tactics techniques procedures
and learning outcomes it clearly
identifies the expectation for the
learners whether exercising Marines
critical thinking and problem-solving
skills or understanding circumstances
were immediate obedience to orders or
application of specific basic skills
such as good marksmanship are required
so there's times where you are gonna
just straight-up say Roger that and got
it and then there's times where you're
gonna have to push back or get creative
additionally effective learning
environments provide opportunities for
Marines to execute the required
repetitions under different conditions
to achieve competency have you ever read
the book outliers no Gladwell yes yes so
one of the things that one of the
experiments that they go through in that
book is there's their training two
groups of kids to throw a ball into a
basket or something like that not a
basketball but just a ball into a basket
and there's one group of kids that do it
at varying distances five feet seven
feet four feet three feet eight feet the
other kids are just doing it at six feet
every single time test day comes the
baskets at six feet guess who does
better echo Charles the six feet people
nope really yep it's the people that had
the variety the flexibility they trained
and they were able to outperform yeah so
that's counterintuitive yeah right we
think hey just do the same thing that's
why that's why I like the multi-sport
athlete has this extra capability and
they tend to do well I just watched a
documentary about different really
successful athletes the often times not
all the time often times the player that
does the best is not the the best
baseball player is not the player that
just played baseball
it's the player the player that played
football basketball and baseball and
then when he was 14 he focused on
baseball but he had all this different
athletic training yeah he was he was
more capable with his body and yes in
moving his body through space with force
I had to go deep on that one yet first
and foremost the learning environment
focuses on the learners needs enabling
Marines to understand develop and retain
the necessary knowledge and competencies
they will use in combat
fast forward although Marines strive for
learning efficiencies improving the
learning environment does not
necessarily mean making it more
efficient for example though rote
memorization and reciting faff can be
very efficient and useful for developing
basic knowledge such as memorizing
standing orders they are not effective
methods for all learning effective
learning often requires approaching
material from different perspectives
applying information in context and
explaining how why actions occurred in
addition to what occurred how many times
Eko Charles have you heard me say you
learn an armlock from a different
professor and from different angles it
will make your arm walk better
so if Dean Lister teaches you an armlock
he's going to show you a couple details
if I teach it to you it's common to show
you a different detail if Jeffy Glover
teaches it to you it's gonna be an even
different detail and each one of those
different levels different perspectives
is gonna make you better then if you
when you learn the arm lock from the
mount but then you also learn it from
the guard both the arm lock from the
guard and the arm lock from the mount
both to get better yes many times yeah
many times better so learning from
different perspectives the important
tool important tool you got to have fast
forward
setting the conditions for success
recognizing these surfaces and gaps
requires awareness honesty and judgment
because they are often unique to the
individual or the specific unit a
surface in one learner or unit may be a
gap in another it is incumbent upon
leaders instructors learners and their
peers to actively seek out these gaps
through continuous and aggressive
reconnaissance learners should not hide
gaps in their knowledge instead they
should exercise intellectual humility to
identify and fill these gaps in order to
improve intellectual humility I mean
that's huge man yes sir that is that is
not easy to do to in front of your peers
especially if you're in charge if you're
like the leader of a team or an
organization or even the instructor
which you know might I'm a top gun and
anything I can think of where I was the
leader of the team that intellectual
humility we call that a brutally honest
self-assessment yeah and what's
interesting is that if you think if
you're not going to be humble and you're
not gonna admit your snake mistakes
you're gonna look stronger to your
troops you're completely and utterly
wrong yeah yeah that when you say it's
not easy to do if it's not easy to do
and you choose subconsciously or
consciously you choose not to do it
exercise in electric humility then is
and you choose to hide your gaps
what's the cold surfaces gaps gaps in
knowledge yeah if you choose to hide
your gaps in knowledge and you and
that's sort of the way you are that's
just how you get good at hiding the gaps
and then you become essentially
successful at hiding the gaps then you
get that so that will stunt your
learning in that way the how its it I
mean actively yes but it makes it harder
and harder and harder though as you go
on yeah you know so it cuz the more you
hide your gaps and the more you're
committed to hiding the gaps the more
like when you get star
to get exposed are you gonna hide your
gap yeah and also you can only hide your
gaps for so long
I mean people recognize it when you
don't have that part of your game it's
not like people don't know it man
man yeah and I'm thinking just two
hundred percent where you know those
guys where it's like man what they don't
want to roll with certain guy you know
like it's everyone sees it everyone sees
what you doing Marines mitigate
weaknesses by leveraging their strengths
to form new understanding and focus on
learning to eliminate gaps this can only
occur when learners first acknowledge
their weaknesses and resolve to leverage
their strengths to build meaningful
connections should we make a poster that
says that no I mean like just so
important and so seemingly obvious and
once again you wonder why someone would
have to take something so seemingly
obvious and put it into a book it's
because even though it's seemingly
obvious it's hard for people to do next
section is called the expeditionary
nature of learning Marines recognized
that to be effective war fighters they
must be warriors scholars they must
seize initiative to study the profession
of arms whenever and wherever learning
opportunities arise and once again I
like I like I like how the the Marine
Corps manuals just state things as a
matter of fact if you're a marine then
you obviously recognize that you need to
be a warrior scholar that's just how it
is now that goes into a little
subsection here
and it's talking about force on force
exercises to simulate Wars complexity
force on force exercises are Purpose
Driven learning environments that are
approximate the complexity of war when
developing such exercises Marines focus
on designs that enhance problem-solving
and promote decision forcing events this
enables Marines to practice and better
understand
and how to get inside the enemy's
decision-making process there is no
substitute for fighting against a
competent realistic thinking adaptive
enemy even if that enemy is simulated by
other Marines this practice ensures that
challenging learning environments
provide a place to practice develop
experience allow errors adapt and learn
how to fight and win that's the very
premise of Top Gun needless to say that
is the very premise of Top Gun that is
the very premise of the advanced SEAL
training where you are in fact fighting
against other seals all the time and
what's what might be hard for people to
grasp and you might even be able to have
a more linear exposure to this I could
watch a young seal officer get better at
decision making events I could watch a
young seal get better at being in
chaotic situations taking a step back
detaching looking around figuring out
what the possibilities are choosing a
course of action executing it
I could watch someone get better at that
it's hard to it can be hard to quantify
what that well like like what that
actually looked like but I'm telling you
I'm trying to tell you what it looked
like it looked like this way I think you
might be able to give a better example
you'd see a young seal day one going
through land warfare training and or
Dave his first we'll call it field
training exercise or his first immediate
action drill in an uncontrolled
environment where he doesn't know what
the call that he's gonna gonna make is
patrolling out there boom the targets
pop up the the simulators start going
off his people react and the first time
it happens to him
he's totally overwhelmed doesn't know
what decision to make he's shooting his
gun he's looking around but not with any
purpose no call gets made eventually the
platoon chief goes I feel right or
whatever then you know you debrief from
you go hey what were you thinking about
when the shooting started well I saw
that target out
of us okay what else did you see uh you
didn't see anything else did you oh no I
didn't see anything else okay cool
next time I don't want you to even shoot
your gun okay same thing happens now at
least the debrief he says yeah I kind of
saw that I saw that little piece of
terrain we could get by that seemed to
be a good spot and then chief made the
call okay so your your your eyes opened
up a little bit more and this continues
down the road until finally he can
actually make a decision on his own in
these pressure environments so you can
watch someone get put into the chaos and
get better at handling it over time what
did it look like a Top Gun similar yeah
very similar and when I was actually
thinking with that is when you're
talking about the progression is the the
end of the progression you know we'd go
through this multi plane environment
which is I think more replicates what
you were doing not just the one against
one but multiple friendly aircraft and
multiple enemy aircraft and it appears
as if the enemy could give you any
number of an infinite number of possible
options to attack us but we actually
didn't do that we had not quite scripted
but some of the basic formations of
basic ways we wanted them to do it and
at the beginning of those phases the
student leaders would come back and just
be like completely overwhelmed and by
the end they wouldn't be they beat
Hannah and they would ask hey what are
you doing so what's so much different
about these last runs or I've been doing
well you're like nothing nothing and
it's when they you would see them
starting to see what's happening and
then their minds are thinking wow
they're either dialing it back or
they're making and we weren't changing
anything but that they were able to see
that time was slowing down their
decisions would make more sense and
they'd ask the question of hey what
change like hey man nothing changed here
what you're able to do now is see and so
the the parallels there are amazing how
similar those two situations are and it
also goes to show how much more thinking
I have to put into how we were doing the
training and where it fits elsewhere
other than just making pilots ready to
go to war yeah that I would get asked
the same question
hey thanks for backing off tonight I'd
be like hey
thank you for using utilizing
decentralized command and letting your
subordinate leaders go on the assault
yeah go on the attack
go on the offense because when you do
that my guys are pinned down they can't
do anything you know how many guys I had
tonight out of out fighting you how many
four you know how many had last night
for you how many have the night before
four no change in the number of op four
you're going against what's what's
changing is your ability to lead is your
your team your subordinate leaders
ability to step up and make things
happen your ability to give good
guidance your ability to make decisions
your ability for your team members to
make good decisions because that's the
other thing that makes it really drastic
is as eight fireteam leaders all of a
sudden you know when when they show up
two of them are kind of proactively
making things happen and then it becomes
three and then it becomes foreign that
it becomes five and then it becomes six
out of eight fire team leaders are
proactively getting after it it's gonna
be hard to contain it and that's when I
would have to step up
I wouldn't back off I would step up my
trade at guys I'd be like okay hey we
need to bring it we need four more guys
when you put somebody over here and we
try and screw them over but we wouldn't
be able to beat a good task unit with
good decentralized command with simple
calls doom cover and move priority we
couldn't week you couldn't beat them you
could not beat that right so you can get
better at this stuff fast forward a
little bit
Marines guard against complacency
because they know that their adversaries
are always watching what the Marines are
doing and they are constantly making
changes to adapt in an attempt to defeat
us if marine settle for what they think
is good enough it may result in high
casualty rates for the next fight
Marines just FYI are not complacent next
question
a learner centric model this is the next
section is called a learner centric
model the learner centric model ensures
that content is relevant to learners
actively engaging and challenging
Marines in a positive instructional
climate for example discussions on
problem-solving between the learners and
leaders and instructors are an effective
method to motivate learners and build
teams as they analyze information
consider alternatives and work together
to develop a solution to the problem
that's posed on them now
I am going to venture to guess that some
of this section is aimed at an old
philosophy of training which existed in
the military well I definitely existed
in the SEAL Teams which is hey we're
going we're here you're gonna do what we
tell you to do if you don't do exactly
what we tell you to do it's because
you're all screwed up and you need to do
it well the way we showed you which does
not promote this whole idea of thinking
and learning and developing you know hey
you you you you entered that room wrong
this is why one of the first little from
the first little things that I noticed
as I'm peeling back my career when I was
at team one today and I was I would be
instructing and I was never the lead
instructor but I go out we'd be doing
some close-quarter combat training and
someone would do something someone were
to enter a room right they enter a room
they'd go left I go right whatever
they make a decision and some of the
instructors some of the more old-school
instructors would say something along
the lines of you went left that was
wrong and I'd say hey why did you go
left and they'd say well when I
approached the door I looked at the
hinges I could see wait which way it was
gonna open and
thought it would be the quickest way and
you go okay here's the thing and maybe
there's a rebuttal to that maybe there's
a hey listen you idjit you know you
can't you can't presume that because you
saw this that's gonna happen maybe it's
the wrong but maybe you go okay I
understand what you were thinking here's
something else to think about but here's
why it mo also may have been correct and
I used to say to guys hey you did what
you did you did what you did look you're
gonna be going into houses you've never
been in before that's the whole goal of
this is that you can go into a room
you've never been in before and you're
gonna react how you react we need to
understand why you're reacting that way
if it's if there's a better way to do it
let's think about it but let's not X out
what you did as if this was the wrong
thing by the way you don't get a second
chance in combat you did you whatever
you just did you just did and now you've
got to deal with it
think about from a leadership standpoint
to what actually helps that person more
then you could do something like Jaco
that was wrong like Roger that do it the
way I told you to do it okay Roger that
you actually made do it the way I told
you to do it maybe you will maybe you
won't maybe you're just stubborn you're
gonna die but you're gonna just do what
you do but if I actually show you like
hey man hey can you just explain that to
me your willingness to listen to me goes
up infinitely and then if there's it for
a time that I go hey man you got to do
this thing you Roger that could do that
but just by asking the question and you
and I almost knew what you're going to
say was hey just tell me why you did
that it doesn't mean that they're still
right but it means that you actually
want to understand what they were
thinking and if you understand what
they're thinking it's so much easier to
train and work with them than if you're
going to try to force them into what you
want them to do and what's incredible is
this section captures that whole thought
process in the title of the section a
learner centric model so if you're a
trainer or you're an instructor so often
people set up instruction as if it's
around Mia right this instruction around
me hey this is how you do an arm walk
right this is how you do it watch me and
then do what I just did
instead of hey let me see
your arm walk you know does this Dean
Lister he'll watch you do something and
when we were at a camp up in Maine
people would say hey be so awesome and
I'd be like oh why they'd say he was he
came from across the room so giant mat
space thousands of square feet of mat
with a hundred people on it and they'd
say he came from across the room and
said hey I see where you're putting your
foot on this position and it'd be better
if you'd move it four inches over here
to the right try it and then it would
work
so it's learner centric it's not about
Dean it's actually about the students
and that's a Dean's very good at that
yeah it's full its fully about the
learner
it's a learner centric model the marine
but I think I think that there is an old
school mentality of instruction in the
Marine Corps possibly I was never in the
Marine Corps but I did go through
multiple training events with the Marine
Corps and I definitely saw some
instructor centric models you know and
some instruct and I think actually Dean
dealt with some instructor centric
models Dean went up to do some
combatives training with the Marine
Corps and the instructors were there and
instead of them being like okay well how
would you do this
Dean Lister multiple time world champion
jiu-jitsu how would you do a rear naked
choke and said they were saying we do it
like this yeah and Dean said okay try
that on me guess what there's some holes
in the plan just next section self and
the caveat haven't thrown it out there
yet no I'm not reading this whole entire
book we're skipping big chunks you can
get it yourself
it's free it's online it's a PDF you can
download it the Marine Corps is very
generous with their knowledge next
section self-directed learning like
mission tactics self-directed learning
benefits the leader and instructor by
giving the learner
ownership and autonomy which enables the
leader or instructor to focus on
learners who need more help or to
explore alternate ways to improve the
learning environment
the commander leader instructor or
mentor agrees to provide the learners
with the necessary support and guidance
to help them accomplish their missions
without unnecessarily prescribing their
actions Oh decentralized command we we
want you to know how to do this we want
you to take ownership of what you
learned why because then you're gonna be
more invested in it it's just I'm good
to go
vicarious experience is critical because
even the most realistic training
experiences in military education fall
short of the reality of combat therefore
the more vicarious experience that a
marine obtains it the less likely that a
new experience in combat or otherwise
will be completely unique yes you can
all simulate everything I used to joke
about the citrate at I would say
unfortunately I can't just shoot you
guys you know and they laugh because we
do everything else I was standing with
the commanding officer of a SEAL team as
one of his SEAL task units was out in
the out in the desert in the Imperial
Valley of California and there was total
mayhem going on and we both have radios
on we're listening to all the calls
getting made there strobes going off
there's there's explosions going off
there's communication whose Duty Act
we're gonna top just all this is
happening and it's we have the perfect
view there's guys on the Richland we're
looking at like a bowl valley and then
guys are up on the ridge lines and you
can see them all from our vantage point
and I just looked at him I said there is
no better training in the world for this
than what these guys are it's so
realistic it was so crazy but my point
was even with that there was things that
you can't simulate you
that you cannot simulate and so you have
to use these vicarious experiences so
that people can learn continuing on
Marines can use mental imagery to gain
confidence prior to executing a skill
emphasize key points in after-action
reviews examine possible outcomes of
decisions and explore options mental
imagery also provides an effective
mission rehearsal technique when using
mental imagery a leader pictures himself
or herself in the operation vividly
visualizes different scenarios including
possible branches and sequels and
rehearses the decisions he or she may
make given specific conditions and enemy
actions this way
the leader mentally prepares for
multiple potential enemy actions and
reduces the possibility of surprise when
the enemy reacts now what you're trying
to do is close the gap between how hard
you can train and what it's really gonna
be like right and you can't look you can
you cannot fully get there you can't
fully get there there's emotions that
you cannot trigger unless someone is
about to could die right now right in
jiu-jitsu right there's you you train
for MMA not even jiu-jitsu MMA we can
throw punches we can grapple we can
exhaust them we can do all these things
but you can't have them walking into the
Octagon in the UFC even if you and I
used to like we when we used to spar
ways to do it on Saturdays when there
was a crowd here get the crowd to start
commenting you can do all those things
but that last little thing you cannot
simulate you cannot simulate and so you
want to build up you want to close that
gap as much as possible part of it is
through the training part of it is
through these vicarious experiences and
reading and learning about them but
there was a guy on EF online today
saying hey I understand that I'm
supposed to detach but there comes a
point when it starts happening and I how
do I get ready for that yeah
and the thing was I the advice I gave my
was a little let's say I was a little
nervous about the advice I gave this guy
because I was saying hey you need to set
yourself up for surprise things that
you're not ready for you actually want
to tell like if I want to get ready to
defend myself and not freak out I need
to tell heck oh hey man occasionally I
want you to have just attack me and
here's where you got to be careful if
you do that let's say you go okay all
right I got this and you start tracking
on me and one night at Vons
you know I'm out there getting some
picking up some steak and you get into
my car or whatever I'm getting in my car
you spring out of somewhere and start
yelling and screaming with a knife in
your hand to see how I react and next
thing you know you got - shit - two
gunshots into the head right yeah and
how am I gonna explain that one away
right it's gonna be tough yes so we got
to be we got to do have to put some
parameters around it yeah because I
don't want to shoot you
yeah wait that's what is that
essentially what I mean obviously not
the shooting thing but that's what
that's what your answer was well what I
said was listen you know talk to your
wife and have your wife throw saneras at
G and then I had to give the same
parameters because if you could imagine
if you said and I said listen you want
to practice being in these turbulent
situations you have to be in them as
close as you can get so I said if you
tell your wife that say hey I want you
to throw some just crazy stress at me
when I you know in and don't even do it
to me today or tomorrow wait like a week
till I really don't expect it but then I
told him hey you need to put some
parameters around this right because his
wife might come home and say his wife
might come home and say I've decided to
leave you yeah it goes good I was gonna
leave you
disaster right exactly so we have to put
parameters on it we have to think
through it but if you really want to to
get someone used to being under stress
that's what you do you put them under
stress that's what you do and it's hard
to do that if you if someone knows it's
a role play there's a little thing in
the back of their mind yeah but if they
don't hey you
you can create a lot of stress on
someone yeah the if you fail that like
those test scenarios that they spring
down at you if you fail that test you
can do some damage and you're really
after what I'm say and you're gonna
begin because I thinking to men because
what if yeah what if your wife says like
essentially a fake unlock like whatever
I'm leaving you I'm mad at you didn't
like uh something small let's say uh hey
you didn't take out that trash or
whatever and just with a slight attitude
yeah what if I fail the test and I'd be
like it's not my job I bring up
something that actually does really in
real life trigger her a little just a
little bit for sure she's playing the
role but a what if she can't detach
either you know which is normal Susan
and now it just escalates from there and
there which started to be a test now man
relationships yeah it's like the office
the fire test with them right right
supposed to be a test and I we got
people throw copy machines out the
window in the military we grew up with
something called and I actually got the
same thing we we had something called
the training timeout so oh yeah in this
scenario like they briefed that okay
we're gonna go do this training and if
something happens that you exceed a
threshold of whatever you put your hands
up on a tee or you put your arm up and
say timeout and then we'll stop the
drill we're just gonna not like
rudimentary training you do that and so
you can I always knew in the back of
your mind like okay this could get bad
but if it gets too bad I can stop the
training wait what would be 13 or what
would be like an example my rec my
recollection of the first time that I
was briefed on the training timeout was
during like the first week of TBS where
we do swim calls it was I got a source
thing you do is call yeah the water is
hey look if you know we're there's five
instructors there's 40 dudes in a
platoon we're watching you but if you
get to a place where you or you can't
handle this you can throw the hands up
and we'll see that will stop the
training so you can introduce this
concept early on and then you know as
you evolved in in fighter aviation we
have the knock it off
which is actually kind of like in some
ways it's kind of like tapping so I can
do this fight with you and we're finally
if I get to a point where I feel like
I've reached the limit naik I don't
think this is safe anymore I can't keep
doing this or or whatever I could say
knock it off and you will stop training
you will stop being the aggressor say
but you don't get to do
in combat there is no training timeout
there is no knock it off but it's
impossible for any training scenario to
remove that thing of hey if your life is
now at risk there is no training
situation that we would love that to
happen we would never get to a place
where you are gonna get hurt or killed
to prove a point but you actually kind
of know that subconsciously and so that
limit is there that's the gap the gap
that's right
the gap is when you've got a platoon of
guys and they're receiving enemy fire
air-quote enemy fire and one of the guys
just gets up and charges you know the
bad guy and it's great and he happens to
get them or whatever but if those are
real bullets the reaction might might be
different right you can't and it goes
both ways too because I used to explain
that's what evens it out for our
training what evens it out is the the
bad guys the OP my op four they don't
care if they die either because they're
there they're gonna get reset and we'll
go again right but actually the
Mujahideen often didn't care if they
died and so they have an advantage there
we care about our friends we care about
our comrades-in-arms
so we're gonna fight a different way
than the Mujahideen that's just they
don't care not all the time but that's a
part of their mindset is hey if I die
that's cool martyrdom yes they would
have suicide missions yes I we don't do
that we don't like hey look you're gonna
die on this and what I want to talk
about that point we don't do that no and
they would at moat they would do that
actually all the time all the time yeah
and that and that the I think the poor
mother is there are things that you
simply cannot replicate and that's
that's one of them not just the risk to
your own life that you're gonna mitigate
but the willingness of the other person
to have no regard for that yeah which is
something is hard you cannot get that
gap will always persist until you
experience it for the first time yeah
and then you gotta try and close that
gap to the best of your ability and the
way you do that is different instructors
different angles and then as we're
talking about here vicarious living
vicarious experience hey tell me what
that was like from you and there's a
chance that you go you know what oh I
know I remember this guy I remember the
I've seen this before this whole book
starts off with Matt is saying hey you
shouldn't be surprised by anything you
should have read about it there's no
there's no thing that you can't say I
seen something like that before which is
what they're going for
all right so going back to the book here
go bet the if to rewind a little bit so
the whole tests about the guy that
you're giving advice to this you know
okay have yourself tested or whatever
yourself it has to put yourself under
pressure scenarios yeah for detachment
practice essentially so I think first I
think those should always be at a level
one that's I think just for safe if
that's really we don't want we don't
want we don't want echo Charles to catch
to Hydra Shok that's a great yeah
Vaughn's parking lot yes as you threaten
my snakes yeah which of your week or
let's say detaching in moments like that
or part of your maybe weakness will say
right which is why I'm actually asked
question for the Train yeah so it is a
weakness yeah so we got to figure
there's some possibility that I am not
gonna detach I'm not gonna see that at
you and I'm just cracking off my rounds
yeah shot plays yes so I think level 1
to I don't know this in my pen but I
think part of or at the very least the
beginning of the answer to someone with
that kind of like a detachment kind of
weakness or whatever is the leadership
primer you call it yes so okay so before
you even said the word leadership print
primer I would essentially prime myself
by doing this and a lot of people do do
this they'll like tell me this and
they'll be like what would Jocko do in
this situation like anytime a stressful
situation came up or a decision had to
be made they'll be like all what would
y'all could do in fact they'll say sure
this is what would you do kind of thing
and like yeah so essentially thought the
same thing but not what would Jocko do
but more like hey I'm the leader so what
should the leader do right now you know
it's like or and then so along with
being the leader is it's your
responsibility you can you cannot it's
against life rules to blame anyone else
you have to take 100% of the blame and
come up with hundred percent of the
solution if someone helps you good but
you have to come with a hundred percent
of the solution right now even if you're
being attacked in feeling
underappreciated
it's 100% up to you to cut to to
manufacture a good outcome so so that's
essentially what would y'all go do right
that's like the press so I would
essentially prime myself like if
something some stressful situation
that's the rule like any stress that
comes in so big or small boom I'm the
leader you just you have to essentially
prime yourself into being like the
leader and what's hard is is is being
primed right cuz you're not walking
around like that it takes a long time to
develop the instinct of your very first
reaction your initial reaction is detach
take a step back and take a breath and
make sure you understand what's
happening that's a really hard thing to
train in yourself it's a really hard
thing to train yourself so for the
leadership primer which again this is EF
online we got this thing called the
leadership primer where you you know you
can just press play leadership
leadership primer and it's me saying hey
this is what you think about this and it
just gets you in the leadership mindset
because if you're there already that's
one less step you have to think hey if I
tell you hey echo you're gonna walk in
that room and you're gonna get into a
fight if I tell you that there's a guy
waiting to fight you in that room you're
gonna do eight times better than if you
just walk into that room thinking about
you know getting sushi right you're
gonna do eight times better minimum oh
yeah you're gonna be ready you're be
primed you can be thinking you're be
looking for an exit you're gonna be
looking for an entrance you gonna see
what is we gonna size up your target all
that's gonna happen the second you walk
in there if you're not expecting at all
it doesn't happen at all yeah so getting
yourself thinking that way is absolutely
important and you know I'll take this
whole thing one step further the idea of
like what would Joc would do cool I get
it as like a leadership primer you
actually have to ask yourself one level
deeper than that which is for lack of a
better way of explaining it
what would Jocko actually do right now
because the surface answer of what would
Jocko do is like oh you just btf through
this right that's the surface answer
it's not the real answer
and that's the difference and I did a
bad job sometimes in the teams of guys
that work with me but they didn't they
got the surface Jocko but they didn't
get the next level and so they go
overseas and have to report to some army
some Army Major that they didn't get
along with and they think what would
jock would do jockle would tell this guy
better straighten himself out no and
actually that's the wrong answer
jock would actually develop an awesome
relationship with this guy get to know
him really well and start planting seeds
in his head where we ran everything
that's what Jocko would do so it's a
little bit deeper than that you have to
go next level yeah before we end up
priming ourselves for hey if it's just
like this if I said okay echo when you
go in this room someone's gonna get
attack you and you walk in first person
you see you punch him in the face and it
ends up being whatever yeah someone that
didn't deserve it right that's a problem
yeah you were overly primed and you
didn't really think through the problem
yes so there's a there's another level
there that you got to go yes I see your
point
correct how can you get yourself primed
you know I talk about leadership
strategy and tactics there's a list of
12 things to do as a leader and I'm like
look you can't read this list of 12
things and be like okay good
cool now know if you're a new leader and
you check in before you go into the
meeting with your subordinate or with
your leader you just take a look take
three minutes and read through the thing
about guard I'm thinking the right way
I've got my mind primed for what I'm
gonna go make happen right now and then
somebody blames me for something instead
of going actually it's not my fault at
all instead you go yeah okay
you know what let me get out my notebook
and actually write down what you're
saying yeah so I can make sure I can get
it fixed because I don't want to be the
person that's responsible for making
mistakes but I'm ready to take it on and
fix it boom yeah and and of cook just to
be clear to like I by no means am saying
people hey do this this is what all you
gotta do it or not all unit this is what
you gotta do
sit ask yourself what would John do I'm
not it like advocating that at all
I'm saying that
a different way of explaining what I
would do and it wasn't like what would
Jocko do it was what would like the
leader quote-unquote leader do and I
used you as a reference and here's the
thing I know you're second and even
sometimes third level like I know I
think I do anyway it's been effective
with behaving like I do put it that way
um so to me I just worked on being that
way at the whole time hundred percent of
the time because it's easier to like
d-prime than it is to like prime one
you're like late on the priming kind of
thing situation and when a situation
arises you know yeah and here's where
all this is hard right all this is hard
is that there's a gap that you gotta be
able to fill that's that's what this is
all about is the gap is I am i can get
primed for so much I can think about
what I'm gonna do and how I'm gonna act
and I'm gonna make this call and if
somebody confronts my ego I'm gonna
detach but then the person that you
didn't expect to confront your ego the
person that you didn't expect to say a
nasty comment to you that happens and
before you can get think through it you
go well who you to even be called out
someone with what you did last quarter
and all of a sudden we've got an
escalation on our hands so how do you
get ready for that the answer is you do
these training scenarios and you as much
as you can you say look hey Dave I've
been having a problem losing my temper
with people can you do me a favor and
just put me through some temper tests
yeah now look we gotta put some safety
parameters about out of it because I
don't want Dave to say I don't want Dave
the says Dave says you know hey joko
this isn't a good example for you to set
a national in front if you're not even
submitting this paperwork on time and I
go well you're lucky or even at Ashkelon
front Dave I don't even know why you're
here and all of a sudden we have a real
bra about this right so let's some
control parameters in place I know and
then immediately Dave called the trainee
time out it's about to get you know
about throwing everything under the bus
why because he was role playing
so yes you got to put parameters on it
but other than that like if you want to
see how you're gonna react
you're gonna react so be careful
no Hydra shocks to your friends chest
because they surprised you trying to
steal your steak yeah a gentleman like a
safe word like the that's what training
timeout is yeah it's like a if it's like
hey IIIi don't you need to stop and you
stop you know who tries to get me to
take some kind of a training timeout
d-lister yeah see and that's the thing
and this that's a whole rap and whole
tube bread there's so many ways to do
that to call for a training time on
because in jiu-jitsu it's like sure
there is the training time out straight
up it's like like hey that's one of them
oh yeah like you can let's say I'm uh
you know maybe kind of injured or maybe
just so super you know let's say I'm a
smaller person less like physical
capability against a crazy you know 21
year old 235 pound weight belt spaz
mm-hm right
I can call a training timeout I can be
like hey like I respect you but this
seems like kind of dangerous I'm not
gonna train with you specific that's a
training timeout really but you could
also be in a scenario where you're out
of shape you have a high level do Jitsu
but you're out of shape and you're going
with the monster guy who's who's really
good at did you see is getting the
better are you
you're gassing you're like you're
getting you're getting beat down this is
what and you kind of don't like that you
can call it a little training how do you
call the trainings and here's where the
subtlety kind of arises you can like
fake an injury you can be like oh like
oh my finger was caught in your shirt
your shorts or you know something to
give you like and again it's a spectrum
you can get like maybe 10 seconds
training time out thing get back into it
or you can give yourself maybe like a
minute or guys used to do I remember
roaming with a guy and he was a higher
belt than me and I was in shape I wasn't
better than him but I was at you I kept
going going going and he kept like and
we're doing G and he kept like coach
take no no take time to tie his belt
again I'm like bro why are you even on
our belts fly off you just keep training
right
he kept liked it and looking like
flagrantly taking like 20 30 seconds to
tie his belt and did like six times
that's a training timeout - the only
thing about I think a training timeout
is is known and
like a training timeout you're talking
about little tactics little sneaky
little khakis to catch a breath but
brother catch a breath over here so it's
a little bit different but there are I
mean tapping out as kind of a training
time out yeah well a training time out
would be like actually remember one used
to be claustrophobic yes sir
when you remember one used to be more
claustrophobic you had kind of your
training timeout was I look I didn't
have a submission on you at all yeah but
you would tap out and to say I there was
a guy when I was a team to that I used
to train with and he would get so mad
and he would just go just get off me
just get off me and then I'd get off me
back oh good and he would be so like mad
at me as a person
Oh for many years because I was putting
this depression yeah I'm putting the
fresh yeah that was weird like when you
would when you would make it known that
you were trying to make me
claustrophobic it'd be less
claustrophobic the most gospel book for
I would get from you is one like you'd
be pinning me down and it seemed like
this was part of your like tactic to
like slowly submit me like I have this
feeling like bruh I'm I'm never gonna
get out of this like situation and I'm
probably gonna die under here kind of
thing but if you're like one time this
is what you did you were like oh you're
better do your claustrophobia now
watched it kind of that you said
something along these lines and then you
put all your weight um and you put your
feet on the wall so all your weight was
on me and you're essentially saying
whatever words you're using you're
saying like yeah like how does that feel
kind of thing and I was like probably
not claustrophobic at all right now you
want to know why you were primed I told
you I was gonna do it you were ready for
it you were ready with the resist yeah
and my mental state was kind of like
this me against you know me against any
claustrophobia situation like my mind
that the battle was different yeah that
is interesting
back to the book Marines need time to
reflect on new learning experience to
exploit their lessons self-reflection
internalizes experience and increases
mental preparedness for employment
across the range of military operations
so you gotta think about what happened a
little thing about Madison here and then
on to general al gray and they're the
some of what it's saying about that
they're saying Marines need to make time
to reflect in order to build
understanding exploit lessons and be
ready to adapt as situations change so
you kind of have to debrief then you
have to debrief yourself next section
the role of the instructor regardless of
the location of location or position
marine instructors are knowledgeable
skilled competent and confident in their
abilities once again this is a statement
of fact that's the way marine
instructors are they're knowledgeable
skilled competent and confident in their
abilities and fast forward a little bit
assessments assessments are employed to
provide learners with constructive
feedback so that they can further
develop professionally rather than an
arbitrary test score that does not
capture growth or change the most
effective instructors use the coach
teach mentor approach to provide
learners with constructive feedback you
know the as we as we covered the code
the evaluations the protocols and I
think I got asked somebody asked me
would you recommend doing this enough it
in a company you know in a company and
I'm like yeah the biggest problem with
the Navy and the Marine Corps evaluation
systems is that their annual certainly
coming out once a year this idea here
that you have to provide assessments
more often than that they don't
necessarily need to be official but
you've got to give people feedback
fast forward learners and instructors
alike should understand that Marines
learn because of their errors not
despite them
isn't that it isn't that up isn't that a
smart thing to think to yourself is that
my employees my subordinates my kids
Echo Charles are going to learn because
of their errors changes your mindset a
little bit when the kids make a mistake
it's their turn to learn next section
technology in support of learning just
as MC dp1 confirms that war is a human
enterprise and that no amount of
technology can reduce the human
dimension the learning environment is
also primarily based on human
characteristics rather than equipment
technology can support expand an
interval individualized learning it is
one of the many tools to support
learning objectives so look it's it's a
tool technology is a tool but it doesn't
replace the human element of learning
the conclusion here battle is the
ultimate conclusion of this section
battle is the ultimate test of military
learning and training as Marines will
fight is a time-honored Marine Corps
principle train as you fight in
preparing for battle Marines leverage
the art and science of learning along
with helpful technologies to enhance
learning environments tailor learning
experiences and provide constructive
feedback to accelerate learning there
you go
and now we get into the last section of
this chapter for the learning leader hmm
it all just kind of comes together in
this section for doesn't it the learning
leader leadership and learning are
indispensable to each other John F
Kennedy the future operating environment
will place new demands on leaders at all
levels our leaders must have the
training education and experience to
meet those demands and that's general
Dunford 36 Commandant of the Marine
Corps and
the 19th chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff and the last quote throughout
history the difference between brilliant
brilliantly performing armies and
mediocre ones has always depended on a
small handful of combat leaders and that
is Dave Burke's friend John Boyd
throughout history
leadership has been the most important
thing on the battlefield small handful
of combat leaders when you're in a in
what's it called when there's a whole
bunch of airplane in the sky one of
those all those airplanes together
called is that like a squadron is that
uh is that a wing you know if you're
going on an assault will you call all
those aircraft together we'd call it an
air wing in the Navy and Marine Corps
and if you're going on you would you go
on a mission like I would go on a
mission with a seal platoon you would go
on a mission with an Air Wing yeah if it
was everybody it'd be the other way and
there's smaller components of that you
know you'd have like section division a
section that's right you'd break them
down much like you know fire team squad
things like that is it true or is it is
it also true in an Air Wing on an
assault that a couple combat a couple
good leaders good pilots can make a big
difference that is true
oh really absolutely we're working
together in pairs basically is that the
smallest unit that we're working in yeah
despite the fact that there is a
narrowing um there's a Marine Corps Air
you know mataf in a wing component and
the Navy hasn't arrowing the most common
formation that we go out there is a two
sometimes a four ship but a two ship
formation we called it a section is the
most common war fighting element when
things break down into individual
implementation to is the minimum and how
many how many aircraft how many sections
would you go out roll out on on a on a
mission that you would train for a Top
Gun and the reason I'm saying that I
collect when you talk about you have
multiple aircraft like sort of the FTX
scenario the final training exercises
how many aircraft are going out how many
sections the top gun with the
culmination or a top gun would be four
sections we eight aircraft eight
aircraft going out to assault a target
they have some some bogeys come out and
a lot and they are gonna try and bring
it and so does the do the sections have
a overall leader yes if that guy's not
quite as good but there's a couple pipe
hitters in there all the difference in
the world all the difference in the
world I think all the same fundamentals
that you've always talked about if you
put them into leadership in the air it's
exactly the same thing it you do not
have to be the mission commander to be
the most influential leader in the
formation legit when you go with the Air
Wing to Fallon Nevada
how many how many aircraft roll out on
those missions now you're talking you
know you could have 20 now you'd have
much much bigger much more complex
different missions all at the same time
a lot more coordination 20 aircraft plus
sometimes then that's the carrier Air
Group going up to fallon to run big
exercises getting ready for deployment
and a carrier group would be you know
three full squashers at 12 you'd have a
squadron of six you'd have a squadron of
four you know you'd have 4050 airplanes
in an Air Wing I did that trip three I
did three strike group carrier
interoperability z' and balance yeah
which is just so lucky on my part as I
was a rate from four to of miles radio
meant for one of them I was J assistant
platoon commander but just the amount of
visibility that gave me because it
wasn't normal for seals to do that trip
we would have a couple seals that were
stationed up there but we but to
actually get up to be able to go up
there and go in the field and do all the
close air support
very very helmets all the way yeah we
did some long patrols to from one end of
that valley over to the other end
Oh twelve twelve kilometers and a night
lay up for the day recover a downed
pilot twelve kilometers back out the
next night did you ever get to be the
downed pilot up there no never did I
know exactly what you're taught oh I
know you got to assign that down
because that guy had to work walk half
those because not a job most people
wanted yeah they didn't seem as
chili-cheese in wintertime yeah we did
every Air Wing and every every course
went through you to have a down pilots
air and you'd send a guy out there
sidetrack two things and two things in
my time in the SEAL Teams where I got to
see something in nature and that a
normal person doesn't get to see one of
them locked out of a submarine in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean and it was
it was the brightest blues at daytime we
were doing a rehearsal it was the
brightest blue most beautiful ocean and
it was not it was incredible visibility
and there was like a pod of dolphins
coming alongside of us and just swimming
that's number one number two I'm in
Fallon Nevada I'm in a helicopter and
it's early spring so there's still snow
on the ground and we're flying nap of
the earth up through these hills and we
come across a pack of wild mustangs
horses that are charging through the
mountains and we're we're we're solo
close to them and they're anywhere like
slightly above the treeline or whatever
I don't know if there's a tree line but
there's no trees the various black
shrubs and these things are just charged
as big pack of my wild mustangs it was
freakin epic one of the coolest things
I've ever seen in nature that's one of
the coolest things I've ever seen
all right so leaders at all levels are
responsible for their own learning while
supporting their subordinates
development each marine is either a
leader or a future leader whether by
rank or by their experience and
influence on another you know that's
something I said at the early musters I
think I said every monster but I would
say training is the solemn duty of the
leaders because if you've got some
training command and they're not doing
what they're supposed to do you need to
still do it you need to make it happen
you're in charge of training you're in
charge of education you're in charge of
making sure people learn an excellent
way to master
topic is to endeavor to teach it well to
other Marines
Marines can develop leadership skills
and improve communication skills through
learning Marines succeed with leadership
styles that provide clear intent through
mission type orders and decentralized
execution we are in full support of this
document if you want to get good at
something by the way teach it yeah teach
it do you think your leadership
capabilities improved since you got -
L'Enfant and you teach leadership I
wrote a note when I was when I was going
through this myself I wrote it down the
word leading is teaching I was just a
note I just put in the in the margins I
was just running through this document a
couple of times the answer to question
is yes I do that is uh that is so it's
you just even the way you describe it it
could be a little bit of a slippery
slope you you said as a leadership
instructor - Ilan front this kind of
implies my job is actually to teach I'm
an instructor I'm here to teach
leadership and it's leadership at all
leaders at all levels responsible for
their own learning I assure you that at
a minimum it's equal and the truth is is
probably ten fall in my favor I have
learned way way way more than what I
have taught in terms of like what I get
because every time I teach something
about I earned something while doing it
and I've told you this a bunch that's
been the biggest surprise of my second
career was having to acknowledge of how
much more that is for me to learn out
there so just that title leadership
instructor if you have the word
instructor anywhere in there I was a top
gun instructor whatever it is your job
is actually to learn and that helped
impart that with other people not just
that you're the teacher yeah I got so
lucky that when I was at SEAL team one
as a young enlisted guy I eventually
went into the training cell and taught
and I taught everything luckily and just
seeing it teaching it you get so much
such a such a much better understanding
of the subject that you're trying to
teach that that's the coolest thing
about being a student Top Gun is that
Marine Corps sends you to Top Gun
come back to be an instructor just in
your squadron you don't necessary the
title of instructor but as a Top Gun
graduate we especially when you're on
the boat if you're not flying there's
really not much else to do so your
training that's all you're doing your
training and so every brief everything
you're doing it's on that doesn't mean
you teach all the briefs it might be
that you take a brand new guy and go hey
you're gonna give a brief on how the
countermeasure system works in the f-18
and you in my mind I might know that
thing like that I could draw that thing
out down to the you know to the to the
battery but this guy doesn't it doesn't
know anything about it and but as the
Top Gun graduate you are responsible
either teaching or training every single
thing that goes on that is the coolest
part about being a top congratulate is
that you're the focal point of making
sure the squadron gets trained and so
you get to be part of all the training
evolutions how many topogun instructors
on average would there be at a squadron
two if you're really lucky sometimes
you'd have a third patch we're pretty
common one maybe two
yeah they ended up kind of by necessity
but also just by design it kind of ended
up that in the suit when I was in the
SEAL Teams in the early days you would
go to training sell at a team the team
owned their own training cell and you'd
be in there and if things worked out
because you were whatever you're you
didn't get have orders for a certain
amount of time or you had already done a
bunch of deployments that put you in
training cell and a lot of guys didn't
want to go into training cell because
hey you know why would you want to go
into training cell you won't you're
there to deploy and I went into training
cell as I was as I was putting in my
officer packages so it was hey going to
training cell and they'll give you some
time to get because otherwise it's what
are you gonna do do another deployment
of course well of course I'm gonna go do
another deployment
luckily the Master Chief Master Chief
faculty you know he told us if you want
to get good at this stuff you need to
teach it you need to come in here and
teach it and thank God because that's
was hugely that had everything to do
because you're de facto detached when
you're instructing by the way when
you're watching guys do immediate action
drills out in the field you're watching
guys clearing rooms you are de facto
detached you're literally watching right
so you can see these mistakes and if you
pay it
tension to it you can learn a lot from
it Marines hold a special relationship
with each other that is akin to the
relationship of mature siblings they
build each other up share experiences
and hold each other accountable this
relationship begins with shared
experiences in entry level training and
instills shared understanding of honor
tradition and the importance of
leadership these are your brothers
learning is necessary to leadership
strong leaders promote learning in
subordinates needs no explanation
whatsoever thank you United States
Marine Corps foster and encourage the
next section leaders model and set an
example of learning for the Marines in
their charge by openly seeking out and
pursuing professional development for
all Marines including themselves in
italics yes the number one person that
you should be getting to learn is you JP
was reminding me the other day that at
some point I said hey you need to start
like this was when we were back in times
and I told him hey here's these websites
you should look at these you know what's
going on in the world you know just not
even news but more Intel kind of driven
websites and it's I didn't remember as
soon as you reminded me I remember doing
that beep but that was me saying hey man
you need to know what's going on here as
stated in MCD p1 which is war fighting a
leader without interest in or knowledge
of the history and theory of warfare the
intellectual content of the military
profession is a leader in appearance
only self-directed study in the art and
science of war is at least equal in
importance to maintaining physical
condition and should receive at least
equal time at least equal time you
should be working out and studying the
professional arms leaders you set an
example with their actions and words
that learning is important for the
profession of arms inspire other Marines
to learn more about the profession and
its application marine leaders
prioritize learning for themselves and
others
taking an active role to foster and
encourage marine learning learning
leaders foster learning by engaging
their Marines taking interest in their
well-being and supporting their
professional development leaders are
justifiably proud when their Marine
succeed
conversely leaders help them overcome
mistakes when they struggle leaders do
not wait for mistakes or failures to
highlight a learning opportunity leaders
provide subordinates with the sufficient
freedom of action to learn and develop
without ceding responsibility to monitor
supervising correct subordinates actions
when necessary
we cannot rightly expect subordinates to
exercise boldness and initiative in the
field when they are accustomed to being
over supervised in garrison the goal is
for Marines to seek learning
opportunities on their own accord even
if the leader is not present present so
they've they've embedded the centralized
command into the process of learning in
the marine corps making it a part of
your very being actually learn and if
you don't do that you're putting your
Marines lives at risk
factual teaching and leading next
section teaching and leading cannot be
uncoupled hmm think about that one Echo
Charles yes
Marines who cannot teach will struggle
as leaders strong leaders do not berate
a subordinate for making a mistake they
turn mistakes into teachable moments no
you know if you imagine if you don't
have control over your temper and
someone makes a mistake and you lose
your temper you've just thrown away an
opportunity for someone to learn you've
you've squashed their initiative all
kinds of problems leaders encourage
Marines to pursue learning opportunities
and cultivate an open dialogue to
discuss lessons learned when mistakes
are made it is the leaders
responsibility to recognize act on and
correct the mistakes by turning them
into learning opportunities
understanding that it's far better to
learn in a training environment than to
make mistakes when deployed
you know it's the idea that you're gonna
you're gonna take people's mistakes and
turning them in teachable moment moments
there's like another kind of thing that
I would see and I still see it and
that's this underlining the underlying
ego that gets involved the little thing
the little thing that you can't look I'm
gonna make this a teachable moment for
you Dave because obviously this was a
little bit tricky for you you know what
I mean like there's that little thing
and even that right there even that
right there detracts from the learning
moment just when I let my ego shine
through my beady little eyes and and
pierce into your ego it's just
detracting from the teachable moment so
what does that look like
just like the way you say it oh yeah
yeah the way I say it the way I come
across with hey hey Dave
clearly that question kind of stumped
you on the web once you want you uh once
you give me a call later I can help talk
you through it yeah you know I'm saying
yeah the whole this the whole vibe all
presentation
it also lets the other person know what
you think of the relationship this is
kind of the nature of our relationship
I'm here to mentor you we get this
question all the time is like hey I
really want to have a mentor I think
your answer is actually really good it
was like hey I never like assigned a
mentor or assigned myself as I mentor
either one you should try to learn from
as many people as you can but the one
that I would see get people fired up the
most is when someone to go bro I'm
trying to help you here and that would
send people off all the time which was
am doing you a favor I know something
you don't know and I'm here to help you
learn even that would put someone who
and look the egos on both sides cuz I if
you were to say that to me even like
that like right on what do you got I
mean that would be my goals of how I'd
respond to that which
easier easier for some people than for
others the egos on both sides but
totally control your own you can only
get you can only if dave has the most
the most totally humble attitude he's
open that's great I got lucky right but
any other guy is going well you know
actually the way the way you talked
about it yesterday didn't even make
sense all of a sudden we're in a
combative mode now what do you know
maybe I'm just running a little trading
Joette good yeah I figured that I threw
that out today I was like I would my ego
tore my tests on Jamie I was like
yelling like pretending like I was gonna
yell at Jamie did you know you were
pretending yeah well I was just using
his example but Jamie was just smiling
because she knows oh I know factually
that Jamie would be like oh okay chuckle
I appreciate it let me let me go find
out because she was deescalate because
she's dealing with this crap all day
long you know that's what she does you
know so she keeps it real real real real
all right
General John a was June 13th Commandant
of the Marine Corps World War one
general the relations between officers
and enlisted men should in no sense be
that of superior and inferior nor that
of master and servant but rather that of
teacher and scholar now I'm going to
hold up right there because that right
there is not correct and if there's a
second lieutenant in the United States
Marine Corps and he's working with his
gunnery sergeant he is by no means by
any stretch of the imagination the
teacher to a student at all it's the
opposite actions right so I I think you
know if you were to take a look at this
in present tense it would read a little
bit differently it goes on in fact it
should partake of the nature of the
relationship between father and son
again that's not a great analogy because
if unless you're now flipping it to the
Gunny is the dad and the second
lieutenant is
is the Sun to the extent that officers
especially commanding officers are
responsible for the physical mental and
moral welfare as well as the discipline
and military training of the young men
under their command that is true yeah I
mean I think I'd picture this in the
context of being a senior officer with
young junior enlisted very young junior
enlisted Marines but and but this to me
kind of highlights some of the problems
with the chain of command now the chain
of command actually can be really good
it's good to have a good chain of
command I'm in a well-defined hierarchy
but there are huge pitfalls in that
because organizationally as soon as you
figure out who you are in the
organization you presume to take on some
sort of set of roles that comes with
that I think on my very first podcast
you I even talked about my very first
job as a lieutenant I got lucky because
I had one of those gunis that was like
right out of the dream scenario who do
you want to be mentoring you and your
first job it was this guy named Gunny
pilgrim who was like you couldn't you
couldn't make a better Marine who was my
subordinate I was his boss and in no way
was I leading him or teaching him or
doing it all it was a one-way
relationship where I just learned
everything I possibly could from him
because he was the type of Gunny that
knew or he was in the chain of command
but also knew what his job was but it
actually does require you to look at you
where you are on the chain of command
and detach from that piece and say where
am I in this relationship and what do I
need to learn from this and if you can
view it like that the chain can really
is sort of insignificant there because
as a junior officer I had nothing
constructive to offer this guy nothing
Gunny pilgrim Gunny pilgrim if you're
listening he knows what's up we're gonna
have to bring out him on here and get
some good stories about second
lieutenant we should vote you weren't
second lieutenant huh were yours
lieutenant you're a first lieutenant by
the time you got to the fleet yeah
leaders going and this know that that
ends that quote and like I said there's
some just some perception in that quote
I think is a little bit off a little bit
off I think it's more like if you if you
just to say you
Ursula on this quote universally what
Marines are to each other
Marines are to each other you know
because I can always learn I can learn
from the most junior guy I can learn
from the most senior guy so just
depending on what dynamics are happening
in that relationship you you know I
might be the the master in one situation
then 20 minutes later you're the master
right that can happen because there's
different parts of knowledge and you got
to be open and flexible to do both those
continue on leaders who encourage an
open discussion with their Marines about
how thoughts and actions contributed to
outcomes will have greater successes at
teaching compared to leaders who simply
point out mistakes for a Marine to
improve upon without context or
explanation yeah then again I think
that's some old school at least in the
SEAL Teams that was morale and it wasn't
always like this but there would
certainly be some guys in the SEAL Teams
in that when I was in in the 90s that
their role as an instructor was to point
out your mistakes and tell you how to do
it right not a conversation just and it
just instruct just direction that
direction is like rote memorization you
tell me to memorize something cool I'll
remember how memorize it I'm actually
really good at memorizing things I'll
memorize it but I what I really don't
want what I really want to do is not
memorize something I want to learn how
to calculate what to actually do based
on thought little note on here about
constructive feedback the goal is not a
simplistic discussion of the right
answer according to a leaders personal
views but rather for the marine to
develop greater self-awareness an
understanding of the situation and tasks
and to be able to adapt the lessons
learned for future situations again not
memorization and like I when I went to
college some of my classes were I I
wanted to get an a on the test
yeah you said this about OCS as well or
did you go to OCS or TBS I was talking
about TBI TBS yeah memorize this okay
Roger that I will memorize this I will
make flashcards
I will member
this and it would have been so much
better if every minute that I had spent
memorizing things I was actually having
a legitimate conversation about what the
meaning of these feels learning in the
middle yeah totally
when I went back you know we talked
about I think it started with the first
one when we did war fighting whichever
one we did the first Marine Corps
doctrine pub you and I did together was
when I went back to start reading these
again and I've we've read a bunch of
them I read this last one I was like
laughing I was I had so much fun reading
this I had no fun reading these pups I
read all these pubs at the basic school
all of them I didn't enjoy any of it
because I didn't have this I wasn't
there trying to learn and the the the
the mistakes that I made I think I've
said this several times looking back if
we could just figure out how to take the
things out of there and have it make
sense in your head and learn something
from it
it's actually fun learning is a is is is
awesome and I was going back through
these pubs as a as an adult thinking man
my experience reading this it was
nothing like this the first time what a
total waste so much I could have taken
from that so I could have learned so
much more so much faster if that's how I
viewed reading these things yeah well
that is a big part of the very nature of
this podcast is hey don't just read it
I'm not just reading this section and
you know that's that how am I putting it
in context with what I've been through
how are you putting it through context
with what you've been through and then
how can someone that's listening take
that and tie them together and say okay
yeah there's you know as soon as you
hear me read from a book and then say oh
that reminds me of I'm just at that
moment in time giving you another angle
another piece of context another way to
triangulate that idea in your own head
which is what makes it worth otherwise
grant although as people just grab the
audio book or just read the book yeah
cool I read the book I even for me for
me getting of course more out of it than
anybody because
I'm reading it and thinking about it and
then overlaying and then getting
feedback about it so it's this it's a
it's a it's a exponential learning it's
an exponential pressure on my brain very
lucky to be in that situation continue
on for example providing topic areas for
discussion using the Socratic method
asking and answering questions to
simulate critical thinking draw out
ideas and identify underlying
assumptions during during debriefs
rather than simply criticizing Marines
actions can be much more effective in
fostering learning positive feedback is
constructive positive feedback makes
learners aware of what they did
correctly reinforces desired behaviors
and identifies areas to improve negative
feedback that unnecessarily tears a
Marine down
seldom leads to effective learning and
can stifle initiative it's a different
mindset this is the type of thing echo
when you're talking about priming you
know and and priming your brain if
you're an instructor situation just
reading that right there before you go
and instruct your class is gonna help
you it's gonna help you teach and it's
gonna help them learn the next section
oddly enough is called humility that's
the name of the section by the way is
just humility when you when you when you
are a 15 year old kid and you are
thinking about which branch of service
you are going to join and then you are
very rapidly coming to the conclusion
that the best branch of service to you
for you to join would be the Marine
Corps you are not thinking about
humility no you are not thinking about
humility you are thinking we are the
best the Marine Corps is the best I'm
going in the Marine Corps because they
are the best
there's no humility in that whatsoever
and you end up realizing that that's
wrong and one of the things that makes
the Marine Corps great and makes any
organization great is humility which is
why they have a section called
humility here we go back to the book all
Marines especially those in positions of
leadership can learn from anyone if they
are ready and willing to learn
however ego can hinder learning
commanders other leaders and instructors
learn from the Marines in their charge
while also leading those Marines to
learn this is what we just said I can
learn from anybody I can learn from
anybody than in command leaders
recognize that humility is a part of the
career long learning process the best
leaders at the highest levels recognize
that the more they learn the more they
need to learn and they set the example
for their subordinates how much you
don't know that's the initial stages of
jujitsu you get they after like your
third class when you think you mastered
the whatever the two moves that you
learned and then you realize oh wait a
second this never stops effective
leaders also recognize that we are not
an expert in every topic so we seek out
those who are experts and learn from
them regardless of relative rank or
position the Marine with the authority
the Marine with authority must make
decisions but until a commander has
reached and stated a decision
subordinates should consider that their
duty to provide honest professional
opinions even though these might be in
disagreement with the seniors opinions
as I call that push back won't push back
I need push back that's how we pressure
test our ideas and of course it's the
marine corps so they throw in until
you've made your decision because unless
that decision comes floor we're gonna
get on board with the program hey what
if it's illegal immoral unethical we're
still gonna push back what if it means
hey we could give a lot of guys died and
killed here on necessarily we're still
gonna push back leadership strategy and
tactics cover that whole thing in ad
nauseam you wouldn't when we're at Top
Gun one of the things we had is
something called a standardization board
which is like the cell the senior
instructors to get together to make
these really hard decisions big
decisions had to be made and as you
might guess you get 26 people
room all Top Gun instructors all kind of
the top of their game you'd have really
really strong opinions and I think what
stood out to me with this comment isn't
like the idea
hey I've made a decision I want you to
get on board it's once we've actually
gone to the mat hatch this out we've
talked everything we've made a decision
what I need you to do is be on board not
that you can't dissent but what I can't
have you do is walk out and be like yeah
we're doing this it wasn't my idea this
is really stupid but that's what the
boss said is not the same as hey we all
argued we put it out there maybe we went
in a direction that isn't what you
wanted
but it's still gonna work and it's a
good idea or we can still do this and
you come and go hey listen there's what
we're doing this is why I'm on board
with this those are two very different
things so questioning those things there
are certainly times that do that but
just because you didn't get your way
doesn't mean that it's wrong it actually
might mean that you need to just get on
board because you might be the one that
maybe you got something to take from
that so when we have these stand boards
kind of the standing rule was when we're
done if you were on the losing argument
that doesn't mean you walk out and go
yeah well I lost that argument
this is stupid I'm gonna do it but I'm
not really gonna do it I'm trying I'm
sitting here travesty I was kind of
racking my brain over here thinking
about why is it that me I in my
experience was never oh it was rarely
that I can even remember in a situation
where I was saying hey guys here's what
we're doing why is that why is it that
throughout my career and life so seldom
that I can't remember an example of
where I said hey listen we're not well
that this is the plan we are going with
why is that I was in here trying to Rack
my brain and it's pretty obvious and
it's like this if Dave comes to me with
his idea and his idea sucks it's very
easy to explain to him that his idea
sucks and he goes yeah you just poke 14
holes in my 15 ideas so obviously that's
not squared away
so that means you know it's pretty easy
to win an argument when you are that
right when you are that right it's
pretty easy to win an argument and and
I'm decent at arguing so if Dave comes
to me with a crappy idea it's not hard
for me to go yeah Dave I get what you're
trying to say but this this this and
this and Dave goes ok I'll go back to
the drawing board so that's one reason
because when I'm right about my decision
it's because you're freaking just wrong
you've come in with a bad idea so that's
parts that's half of the solution that's
half the reason why I'm not saying hey
everyone no more discussion this is what
we're doing that's 50% the other 50% is
because when Dave comes to me and says
hey here's what I think we should do and
it's 13 or 12 or the points are pretty
good and even though I could lock down
15 out of 15 I'm totally good with going
sounds good Dave you win roll with it
and what does that mean the amount of
times because otherwise if I say no Dave
my 15 ways my 15 points are Betty and
you're like no my 13 and we get an
argument on and finally I say shut up
and go do what I told you to do and now
you go do it you resent it you're pissed
off and whatever but 50% of the time or
50% the solution for me is hey you're so
wrong that you can't argue with me and I
don't say that but I just point out all
the things and you go yeah good point
good point good point and and you're not
gonna you're not gonna fall on your
sword when you are just blatantly wrong
people don't do that even the most even
the most Doug in person when they get
shown the 19 reasons why they're wrong
they retreat so therefore we all go out
with the same plan or you come with a
plan that's freaking close and I go
sounds great man let's execute
coming down the chain of command meaning
how many times did someone tell me hey
Jocko shut up and do what I told you to
do
again racking my brain a little bit
can't think any off the top of my head
why same thing most of the time when my
boss had a bad idea I was able to
articulate and convince him of a new way
of doing it that made more sense or I
was able to say you know what that'll
work
I can make that work I can make anything
work I can make that work you know this
isn't a this isn't a suicide mission
this may not be perfect but I can go out
there and mitigate the little downfalls
no factor so that's why when I read
these things it's like I I know what
they're talking about but I very rarely
experience it very rarely experience it
I can't even at national on front the
amount of times I've said all right guys
lock it up this is what we're doing I
think we thought about one of them is
like a PT evolution at the muster muster
of the four or something where there was
a crazy plan floating around I was like
you know what there's a lot of risk with
that plan there's no risk with a known
plan what hey we're just gonna go with a
known plan yeah by the way we have a
minutes by the way we got like seven
minutes actually this thing we got to
make a decision that's like one of the
few almost every other time
and if we would if I would have done a
better job saying hey briefed me on what
we're gonna do tomorrow and we can do a
run a dry run and all that I would have
been able to say hey we would have gone
through the cycle of actually figuring
out a whether that plan would have
worked which it might've or B what
little adjustments we need to make and
then everyone's happy
this mentality of open discussion hinge
of so by the way all this revolves
around open discussion right all this
revolves around me listening you talking
you listening me talking it all revolves
around that this mentality of open
discussion hinges on the leaders
willingness to remain humble and accept
honest feedback
therefore all Marines prepare themselves
to become leaders by exercising humility
and being open to constructive feedback
boom this is a message to everyone in
the world
continuing on the path to mastery starts
out starts with a sense of humility the
path to mastery starts out with a sense
of humility Marines recognize that they
do not know everything and therefore
must remain humble as they pursue
greater understanding and competence
Marines should always recognize that
there will be more to learn and they
must embrace their curiosity in order to
continuously learn curiosity will lead
Marines to knowledge required to fill
their own gaps and experience and
improve their skillset and that
curiosity is tying back to what I
started this whole thing off with me
like wanting to know a better way is
there a better way to do this is that
tradition right is that standard
operating procedure correct when a
Marine begins to feel more confident it
is because he or she is closing the gaps
between their goals and their actual
capabilities reaching a goal along the
path to mastery is an indication that it
is time to move on to a more challenging
goal boom next section technical and
tactical proficiency Marines begin their
pursuit of mastery by developing
brilliance in the basics of technical
and tactical proficiency and all levels
technical and tactical proficiency
requires Marines to reflect upon what
they have learned identify learning gaps
and close them self-reflection enables
Marines to evaluate the quality of their
practice recognizing that deliberate
purposeful quality practice leads to
mastery in correct practice and lack of
focus does not lead to perfection it
leads to negative training that could be
transferred into the battle Space
Marines focus on doing the both Basics
correctly building speed and agility
know no reason to get crazy it's a
pick-and-roll
there are many technical skills that
Marines learn some are standard battle
skills training and others vary across
military occupational specialties
Marines build foundational technical
skills such as marksmanship and
operating as part of a team in
entry-level training Marines learn to be
technical profession as riflemen which
provides a common identified entity
among all Marines the larger lesson for
Marines for all Marines to learn is the
hard work dedication and persistence
required when seeking self-improvement
hmm that's what you're learning in boot
camp that's why every Marine is a
rifleman not yeah look do we need you
know how do you work your rifle yes we
do what's more important than that is
the lesson that you learned and that it
takes hard work dedication and
persistence that's what it takes that's
what you learn from becoming a rifleman
Marines build on this lesson as they
move on to the next technological
challenge and then it kind of advances
here into the larger picture
Marines develop teamwork and
competencies so that they are
technically and tactically proficient as
individuals teams units and mag tops
collective learning experiences build
teamwork that enables success teamwork
building exercises provide the
opportunity for marine leaders to both
lead the development of their Marines
teamwork and learn from these exercises
during these learning activities leaders
who demonstrate humility by discussing
what they did and why subordinates to
reinforced learning at all levels of the
team learning takes time dedication and
diligence and the pursuit of mastery and
the reason I had to call this out is
that in an organization the organization
is collectively also learning that's the
best of big separation between like
basic SEAL training and even the net
when you get done with basic SEAL
training then you go to SEAL tactical
training or what they call now a SEAL
qualification training both those are
pretty much individual skill sets it's
not until you get into a seal platoon
now it's collective learning now you're
learning how to do things as a platoon
which is totally different and yet
builds upon what you learn to do as an
well what was the training that you led
what was the the title of that training
news West Coast SEAL training was that
is that sqt or what was that called
again I know that's a pre-deployment
workup pre-deployment plead a
pre-deployment training cycle I usually
call it advanced training even though
technically the and if you looked by the
book the advanced training that is run
is actually advanced individual training
that's what they call advanced
individual training which is hey you're
gonna learn to be a sniper you're gonna
learn to be a parachute rigger you're
gonna learn to be a medic
those things are advanced training is
what they call it the simplest way to
explain what I did is I just call it
advanced training there's a seal that
would be sitting in the audience go you
didn't run fans training it's like no I
ran advanced collective platoon training
so it's simple way to put it is to say
advanced training even though there's a
technical there's a there's a command
called advanced training it's ATC
advanced training command and they teach
dive supervisor they teach radio men
they teach individual skills but it's
what I taught was the advanced and
usually what I actually call it as
advanced tactical training cuz that's
what it was and that's what it still is
it's advanced tactical training it's how
do you and that's the unit collectors
cover unit level trainings that we and
actually now that you say it what I
actually taught is called ult unit level
trained on it how much just hearing you
say that
how much has buds evolved and changed
what they did compared to what you did
and how much that of all ya unit level
training involves all the time all the
time right buds is a if buds is what
buds is and you can you know there's
there's something if somebody that went
through buds in 1964 went and watched
buds right now they would go oh yeah oh
yeah we did oh yeah then they'd get a
lot of reminders if they came and watch
the seal platoon going through urban
warfare training they'd be like damn
they'd say damn now the land warfare
stuff has been it's it's really been
very similar although now I can't even
say that because we have the the laser
tag system we got all the but they would
do pyro and stuff but we the laser tag
system and the paintball and stuff was
just I was around when paintball started
to come out in the SEAL Teams and it and
it changed everything for us it changed
everything for us
because unfortunately most of the
Vietnam guys were gone and so all of a
sudden we started doing wrote things
wrote things meaning here's the problem
here's the solution and that's not what
a learning organization does they don't
do wrote things no they don't do wrote
things but hey if you get contacted from
this position in your patrol here's the
rote answer to that do that thing and
what happens is the enemy that you're
going against is paper targets they
don't move and they don't shoot back
they don't maneuver and they don't chew
back well guess what that's actually
what combat is combat is fired maneuver
and now you're going against an enemy
that doesn't maneuver or shoot back it
doesn't cover move doesn't four-hour
move doesn't do anything so you it's
it's it's not that it's worthless
because you will learn what the
mechanics of movement are yeah yeah but
and and we used to do this too we would
do no fire drills where hey you're gonna
get contacted from a bunch of different
places but you're not shooting or we use
blanks we used it's gear did you ever
used it's gear oh no it's not dead gear
what's up miles miles yeah yeah so ditch
was like the modern for us in the SEAL
team ditch was the modern version of
miles gear miles gear was kind of it had
it had a lot of it had a lot of had a
lot of issues with miles gear the old
miles gear that we had in the 80s and
90s how it wasn't it you know didn't
work really well and it was just it
wasn't great and you couple that with a
bad attitude which is here's something I
heard gonna do was um was its gonna give
you training scars like they would say
that about paintball they'd say hey if
you're using paintball guns you're going
get training scars a meaning I'm gonna
forget how to load my real weapon
because I'm used to reloading a
paintball gun and so now when the moment
hits I'm fumbling around looking for a
hopper to put my more paintballs in we
can't do it because of that and what
that essentially does unfortunately
throws the baby out with the bathwater
because the training scars that you get
from only fighting against paper targets
are worse than the training scars you
get from having to use a different
weapon to run these scenarios yeah so to
go back to your point and I see where
you're going with this the basic level
training of individuals has advanced and
evolved a lot less than the unit level
training where we were constantly
adapting from what was happening on the
battlefield what is that
similar for you guys I mean if I went
through flight school right now it would
look very similar to World War 2 flight
school that thing is not evolved and it
was just this idea of what a learning
organization was it's that the
organization has to learn and look and
I'm sure it's true for buds you can
describe it but you know OCS primary
flight training they serve a very
specific function but that function is
not to teach war fighting and so the
evolution of those organizations really
isn't that dramatic it doesn't change
very much because it's teaching these
fundamental skills that are absolutely
required but they're not the skills that
you would utilize in the only schools
utilize for war fighting I just think
this point is a leader when when you
read that idea about the learning
organization is that a learning
organization evolves and adapts and
changes and right back to the what you
started with it was my story at Top Gun
which was you actually need to be out in
front of that and leading your
organization so your organization is
designed to learn the or the organism
that you're a part of learns and when
you start in the military like OCS or
bootcamp or even a little bit TBS I bet
if I went back to OCS right now I'd
exactly yeah that's that's about right I
see you guys marching on the grinder I
see guys ripping their bed sheets off
their racks and throwing their
mattresses on the floor I see people
yelling and screaming and it's probably
looks much closer and if I went back to
if
we're wing training a TopGun up at far
now damn mm-hmm you guys have up your I
guarantee you I'd say you guys have
upped your game a lot just because I've
been out of it you know for long enough
because that is a learning organization
that's really I think the goal and I
think again the parallels are pretty
obvious and how clear that is and it's
not to imply that those basics aren't
important they're critical but and they
mention that in here just a little bit
ago they're saying look what Marines do
is get brilliant at the basics yeah and
when I was running trade at I actually
changed the terminology that we use to
describe basic I ads I changed it from
basic to fundamental metals yeah because
it's truth because guys we think well
I'm walking into the basics but these
are fundamental right fundamental this
is what it actually all boils down to
these things these fundamental things
and you know what there there have been
changes but guess what's never changed
cover move keep the things simple
prioritize and execute decentralized
meant those things have not changed and
I don't foresee them trying to change a
conclusion strong leaders are also
teachers and mentors every Marine is a
current or future leader and therefore
leads by example to seek learning
opportunities for themselves and other
Marines all Marines especially those in
positions of leadership should strive to
remain humble so they are ready and
willing to learn from anyone at any time
in any place learning is an
institutional priority and a
professional expectation for all Marines
continuous disciplined and progressive
learning is necessary for warfighting
readiness learning is the foundation for
all that Marines do it is the key
enabler for all war fighting functions
think about that statement learning is
the key enabler for all war fighting
functions and our purpose as the
nation's
evil expeditionary force in readiness
Marines learn to quickly recognize and
understand important information adapt
make sound decisions and act which is
especially important in the fog and
friction of war all Marines must
understand that continuous learning is a
priority and key to our readiness as the
nation's first line of defense always
being ready to be the first to fight and
that's the last line of that document
aside from a giant bibliography of all
the different documents that they cite
in there many of which are actually
other Marine Corps pubs which would seem
like oh that's incestuous if those
original pubs weren't so freakin solid
but that idea that learning is the
foundation for all that Murray's doing
it's the key enabler the key enabler to
be able to collect absorb and understand
information and then use that
information to make good decisions and
execute is all all based on learning and
that obviously doesn't only apply to
Marines you know applies to everybody
and I'll tell you I think we've been
we've had this Wow long have we been
that window
what is this better been about month
cycle of us with this document it's been
about a month yeah I have been paying
attention and have realized what a
better understanding of what I haven't
realized fully what it is but I have a
better understanding of learning and
that I have been learning and more
important what difference it makes when
you are proactively learning when you
are actually engaging your your your
putting pressure on your brain to
proactively learn makes a huge
difference learning because you're
experiencing something or learning
because you are being taught like think
of those two things learning because
you're experiencing it and learning it
because you're being taught that's one
level of learning but when you learn
because you are actively engaging your
brain and processing information and
making it part of your usable knowledge
hey I'm not just taking this fact than
storing it in there and not being able
to take it out and recollect it not only
recollect it because who cares about
recollecting it but taking it to apply
it to a problem and solve a problem or
use it look what are the chances that
you come up with a problem that fits
this thing that you learned and it's an
exact fit no you gotta take six
different little elements that you've
learned actively learned you've engaged
your brain and you apply a little piece
there and a little piece there and a
little piece over there and then you
have that knowledge and you use it and
you apply it and that is the deal that
is the game changer and that is learning
we're pretty fired up about learning
over here on my side uh echo Charles
yeah them you making the point with like
I say usable mm-hmm usable knowledge
we're totally different thing so that's
weird cuz okay so you don't remember
when you're in school I don't know think
Brooke were you a good student I was
okay you seem like you you're like you
do as opposed to say no I was I was not
a troublemaker yeah I was quiet I did
well in school I did not work very hard
so I wasn't like a studious guy I didn't
like try hard at school right okay so
for lack of a better way of putting
maybe just happen to get good grades
kind of thing given kind of who you were
you could say that I guess sure I would
say that but I will also say jockle what
were you a good student in high school
yeah no okay so a lot of it seems like
in squeal hey learning should be fun
which you said by the way today learning
should be fun right I've heard that
before learning fun I'm like Jake
Bateman actually I like it I yeah as an
adult I think we can realize that a
little bit more especially when we're
into learning but you know how like when
you're in school they're like you're
learning should be fun you're like well
I'm doing it wrong because this is super
boring you know like playing at the park
is fun the slides fun recess is fun
lunchtime fun learning part not so much
pretty boring and this is what I think
is this is why I think because it's not
usable knowledge in your brain it is
long-term that's the for sure but you
don't if you don't feel it you don't
feel that I'm gonna let y'all go talk
cuz I actually I'm not I'm gonna say so
because it might be kind of what wait it
I just said I had fun reading this I had
fun reading this book this pub I had it
fun doing it which is kind of crazy to
think about cuz the first time I did it
was just purely a chore
I actually think learning is fun so I do
stuff with my kids I got a six-year-old
boy like we're doing things now he's
able to do things with his hands that
built up and he's learning things and
he's having fun doing it
it's what is the problem is that the
inability to make the connection that
everything they're learning even the
ones that feel like a chore if I could
somehow convince my kid listen buddy I
know it doesn't make sense right now but
there you will one day make the
connection between this and other things
if I could which I can't do cuz he's six
if I could help him make that connection
he would be much happier learning things
that don't make sense under why he's
learning them it's the inability to make
- the connection the thing of it is is
that you said something had to go like
since I crack this thing open I like I
said this to you a little while ago hey
dude this is coming out they're about to
publish this thing even in the last
month I am looking around and seeing
things that I've been look around and
seen in my entire life and that's
because I can make the connection
between learning things and how it
creates not just the usable knowledge
but how it makes my life better and
helps me be better at what I do
it isn't that if you could make that
connection for your kids and I think
that's the hardest part for me is hey
but we can't just all do the things that
you're enjoying we gotta do some of
these other things too they're important
but I promise you they'll have value and
meaning that's hard to make that to
cross that bridge and make that gap for
a six-year-old but I've never seen
anybody who learn something not enjoy
learning it once they figured out what
they're doing yeah you were so close so
close you are so close to just taking my
thunder away you were so close I'm glad
I gave you the opportunity to attempt
and you were dan you were dancing around
it you were dancing around it and tell
me if I'm wrong well I was thinking and
like man I'm gonna start saying
something he's gonna say and every time
I try and say something he's gonna say
echo says if you could say it like him
it'd be better so I almost I should have
just followed my instinct which is the
same nothing you were you were dancing
around what I was thinking okay which is
this you're saying hey you've got this
thing and you can't make a connection
the future I'm gonna but I'm gonna take
that one step further imagine this the
the which I thought you were gonna say
is the key phrase and then I thought you
were gonna say is the key phrase the
application of knowledge actually being
able to use it is where that connection
gets made
so when you
teach your son how to do something that
he can apply immediately that's fun
imagine if in jujitsu what you had to do
was do an armlock on a on a uh what is
it a grappling dummy that that's what
your lessons were would that be fun
right
marginal okay this did you not want to
give me a solid answer that what's more
fun arm locking a grappling dummy or arm
locking a training partner training
Prince let me ask you this how many arm
locks have you done on a grappling dummy
hmm
okay how many arm locks have you done on
training partners 1 million exactly so
this every what what you said they've
totally accurate and I think where that
connection actually gets made is when
you are have the Cape but how the
opportunity to apply that knowledge so
if you teach your kid something and all
of a sudden they go to the store and you
go hey it's 78 cents you know get out
the coins and the kid gets to take out
three quarters and three pennies and put
him on the table and he applied that you
give them a knob boom the Cassiar goes
same you know thank you son so as much
as we can if we can teach people
something and then we find an avenue for
them to actually apply that knowledge
and who knows maybe this could maybe the
the the goal is to actually teach people
in stages where you're teaching them
things that they can actually apply like
if you can set it up that way
that you're not trying to teach them
advanced physics before but when there's
no application for it but then when they
get to a point where you can start to
say hey you want to check out you want
to know what the tides gonna do we can
actually figure that out from us from
from astrophysics we can actually figure
out here's what it is and here's how it
works and then people say so yeah
application of knowledge what do you
think Dave yeah dude totally and the
piece that I still am grappling with it
the larger connection and I wish I could
say it more clearly
is the piece that I'm struggling with
and I think most people struggle with is
what you're learning doesn't have to be
applied in that same way meaning so hey
you learn the teacher came out account
money and then he gets account money but
if I were to tell you that you could be
better at arm locking your opponent by
reading the Marine Corps pub on strategy
because there's something that makes you
think and see differently and some
people don't wanna read that stupid book
as it has nothing to do with what they
want to do actually actually it does and
if you can make that connection of this
thing that seems totally irrelevant to
your world I don't like math I'm never
gonna go be a math teacher or my
daughter will say I'm not good at math
and I'm never gonna go be a whatever
there's a connection there to every
other thing that you're doing and that's
a gap that's hard to bridge like it's
not that that you're gonna go but you
don't think we become a mathematician
from that to be important and fun in
your life I'm gonna stop there because I
whatever you have to say but that's the
gap that I'm talking about oh that's
that's the original idea of the thread
right the original idea that thread is
like all these things are connected
totally and if you realize that they're
connected then you'll understand them
better and the better you understand
this scientist from 1820 yeah the better
you'll be able to relate to this artist
in 1904 like those things are real and
and the mind the brain is a muscle that
the more you use it the more you utilize
it the better you can respond and so
yeah I think you're actually absolutely
right that's when when and I was kind of
stuck in the six-year-old brain right
because it's really hard to explain to a
six-year-old hey this math that you're
learning is gonna help you give you a
greater capability to win in a soccer
game right like that even though we all
know it's actually true because you're
sharper you're smarter they have a
million reasons so finding it the
finding the application of it and when
you recognize that application and I
think that's where I've been very very
lucky because at some point again at
some point I said oh I can take what I
learned in jujitsu and I can apply it to
combat and I can apply it to leadership
and by the way
I can take something that I learned in
leadership and I can apply it to
jiu-jitsu and although all the way
across those those those modalities and
by the way those modalities as soon as
you step into some other modality you if
you have the open mind you see the
application again and you see it again
and you're see it again I mean we do
this all the time at echelon front when
we're working with a company that we've
never worked with this company before
and you take a look at what what they're
doing how they're doing it and you can
apply the principles that we know and if
you don't understand that look you got
to take this little piece of this at
this principle and this little piece and
you put them in place and look we get
people at echelon front clients that
they've read the book thousand times
they've listened to every single podcast
and as soon as you roll in and you start
talking about it they don't quite have
the skill yet of maybe how to apply it
and as soon as they see how it applies
all of a sudden their mind yeah expands
and you go back three months later and
now they don't need they don't need us
anymore they don't need a salon for
anymore they've figured out the
application process and that's where
they go next level yeah totally
speaking of learning gecko Charles
closing the knowledge gaps yes speaking
of closing the knowledge gaps by the way
don't hide them hide lot knowledge can
you know what I think it's fun as an
adult
I think more so like when you're young
and maybe this has to do with part of
the brain maybe not I don't know from
what I hear it does when you're young
everything is short-term everything sure
did like the long-term well the brain
has a hard time to comprehend that you
know so like you get students like young
students or whatever who get really good
grades but that tends to be because
their goal is to get good grades it's
not to like learn math so I can apply it
to life necessarily maybe that's what
they're told maybe maybe not but as far
as their actual like desire to learn the
math it's like to get good grades Trey
you ever done okay so I taught my
three-year-old how to chew slingshot
right shoot a slingshot check so I shoot
a slingshot you watch at three
year old boy by the way I mean you know
probably girl too but um shoot a
slingshot at a bottle in front of a
three-year-old thinking I think it's the
most awesome thing in the world and they
say oh yeah you try he doesn't know how
he doesn't know how to put the thing in
he gets all mad or whatever I teach him
he's focused on that thing like man this
is I'm gonna learn the world's solutions
right now this is the best thing in my
life and I need to learn this tre teach
them how to like memorize the alphabet
he'll be like Braille listen to you but
but I'm not into this right now you know
it's just night and day you know or or
try to do a puzzle with a kid you're
just looking for that one piece that
fits and when it fits it's like cool but
meanwhile as an adult you're like cool
that is cool
that's good incremental like progress
that we're making but it's really cool
when this whole corner is developed and
then this whole corner is you and then
you put them all together and boom the
big puzzles seem sane it's like a bigger
picture kind of thing
mmm we're thinking anyway that's why I
think and then not to mention when
you're into an adult what you're
learning tends to be something you chose
to learn and that's already you're just
already going on that path of fulfilling
like little gaps in your knowledge that
you need to be filled you know so like
actionable knowledge kind of thing it's
already been gonna be set up like that
just just by the very nature of you
choosing what to learn something yeah
that's what that's why that's important
for parents teachers human beings to try
and get the kids to recognize what that
thread that that thread ties everything
together
then the long because if we're learning
for short term we're learning for shirt
or short term and it's hard to see where
it all ties into with that
so speaking of long term short term
learning what do you got for us echo
Charles you have I'm gonna go with the
knowledge gap situation that really
because it's a big one hiding knowledge
gap or closing
oh yeah closing and therefore closing
closing yes so jiu-jitsu let's face it
let's face it I don't need to learn how
to fight right because I don't fight
yeah
if that knowledge gap is exposed in the
real world you can have a problem we
aren't gonna have a problem so let's
close that knowledge gap won't take
jiu-jitsu when we take you to - what I
mean
jujitsu training gear mm-hmm give your
name key rash guards even doing no key
okay so we're getting all this stuff
there's more stuff by the way or Jemaine
calm nice we can give you keys best keys
in the world american-made 100% are we
back making jeans
yeah we are making jeans we are back in
the game
jeans are being made good you can order
them and you will get them we have we're
making so if you don't know we started
making masks face coverings actually
because we don't want people to get
confused and think that this is a and 95
masks they're not but there's
recommendations from all kinds of people
including law enforcement that will find
you here in the state of California if
you're not wearing a mask
okay yes is that under certain
circumstance you're outside started May
1st no kidding yeah so anyways at origin
we started making masks so that people
face coverings so if you want to get
those go to origin main comm you can
also get a bunch of other clothes
including jeans yes you can also get
let's say you're in lockdown at your
house you didn't have a gym no gym your
gym is shut down because of kovat 19 now
you have no weights no gym what are you
gonna do well you want to workout you
want to Train guess what you can get
from orange and Maine to items right now
one of them is a plyo box right you want
to get your jump on and there's all
kinds of things you can do with a bar
box know what I do over the plyo box
push-ups yeah push-ups yes jumps yeah
all that stuff you know exciting stretch
oddly enough sure it's one of those
things you use it to get yourself in
positions that force you to stretch and
I am NOT a good stretcher yeah
and then we also have something known as
the burden the burden which is a what
would you say it is a leather kettlebell
it's a leather kettlebell so it shows up
to your house with no weight and then
you can fill it with whatever you want
to fill it with my recommendation
actually pennies go to your bank go to
your bank and get 50 to $75 worth of
pennies
load them into the burden so stitch it
up not stitch it but you tie it up it's
like shoelaces and then you have you got
about a 30 to 40 pound kettlebell
depending on how much you fill it up
yeah dang that's a good idea
pennies are heavy men pennies are heavy
and they're readily available they have
them at the bank there's gonna be a run
on pennies in a minute they're gonna go
up yeah you know they were going out
they're phasing out pennies they were
well well he didn't have them at the
bank yes they do they do yes they do I
heard like five years ago that they're
straight-up phasing pennies out of the
whole game the cool thing forty pounds
might seem light for a kettle bell if
you've never used to get all bailed
before and you don't work out you're
gonna be surprised forty pounds as heavy
is more than you're gonna have to go
lighter than that but dealing with the
burden because it's pliable it's
actually harder to you it's harder to
work with in a kettle bell yeah so like
you know a kettle bell is harder to work
with a barbell because it's odd shape
and it's whatever yeah this is one step
even harder yeah so you can get really
kind of savage workouts just with the
burden yeah yeah that makes sense cuz
it's like you know that's the whole
thing with like like sandbags yeah yeah
you know that cock word yeah The awkward
is like working more muscle you have a
burden Dave no oh dang your
relationships must not be a very good
right now over at origin well it's a hot
commodity that thing is good man yeah
well we sold out immediately but we got
more leather so we're back in the game
making them happen with burdens yes more
burdens for the world yeah it was good
carry your burden well also boots are
we're back doing the boots thing
do you have boots right there no no
boots either very bad relationship so
either that or or they know me really
well you probably don't wear boots so
check yeah makes sense yeah well yeah
you won't wear boots like just around no
I don't wear boots just around yeah
but when I go on the road yeah yeah yeah
cool makes sense everything at or
Jemaine calm also supplements if you are
not keeping your joints in order you're
not gonna be happy big picture because
after a while they they they jam up
trust me
so yes joint warfare from chaco joint
warfare a creel super krill oil mm-hmm
also we have the discipline keep your
mind in the game your brain in the game
Dave Burke it's super excited about the
discipline pretty much daily not pretty
much it's actual daily yeah a we spun up
some more cult for to so I was yeah if
you if you need that little immune
system hater you can jump on the Cold
War and get some of that the cans of
discipline go ready to drink and there's
a new flavor that will be coming out
actually there's a couple new flavors
that we coming out one of them is called
sour apple sniper the Jaypee Danelle
signature and then also we will be
announcing afterburner orange the Dave
Burke signature models and then echo
Charles we don't have a name we don't
even have a flavour yet but you know I
sensed in the room today when we started
talking about afterburner Orange let's
just say some of us weren't as excited
and maybe thought that maybe they should
have their own what it talking about
rather setting
I think you need your own flavor right
well thanks but yes yeah
I I got a sample of the sour apple
sniper dude it is so good and I I did my
first two samples of the afterburn
orange right now that's our upper sample
they have that they've dialed that thing
in that thing was good yeah it'll take
it'll take some iterations yeah I don't
- I did - I've done two trials so far of
After Burner oh yeah I got the first two
got the family everybody got in on it
tried it yeah it's just gonna take it
takes iterations okay get it there the I
mean for the first Mulk
for mint milk i went through ten
iterations try it again try it again try
it again and then finally I was like be
up there it is so all that good stuff
warrior kid mulk doc a white tee man I
made a jock away - the other day like
from the teabags that is so legit and
all this stuff is available at the
vitamin shop at the vitamin shop is open
in your area right now since we're all
knocked down you can check it all out
their origin main dot-com origin main
and a I n E or domain.com for any of
this gear and it does support yes the
whole game the whole system really also
chuckle has a store and it's called
Jacko's store so super original yes we
go to jakka store calm and you can get
you know what do you much the the kids
how the kids say enough merch off yeah
the last t-shirts hoodies more rash
guards beanies some women's stuff on
their tank tops and whatnot you know
discipline equals freedom you know the
whole the whole how should I say as far
as representation goes you will be
representing the path will say that I
got a good quarantine shirt on there too
if you want to represent in lockdown
you're still putting in the work you're
still doing your decline push-ups on the
plyo box you're carrying the burden
seems saying and you want to represent
we got a good quarantine sure free look
good on got women's tank top two tank
tops too by the way anyway chuckles
stored up come good stuff one I'll just
leave that out there for you yeah yeah
it's good man subscribe to the podcast
if you haven't yet leave a review so we
can read it
hopefully it's funny hopefully it's
impactful also got some other podcasts
got a podcast called the thread the
episodes are out there on YouTube it's a
different what is it podcast feed what
is it called yeah it's called the feed
that's true so there's a there's a
different feed for the thread there's a
different feed for grounded so the
thread is about well it's about we were
just talking about threat of things how
things connect together in the world and
we myself Darryl Cooper of Margar made
or I've been doing that podcast it's
been it's been wild to be honest with
you he's bringing things up in my mind
you know making me remember things one
of the coolest things that he made me
remember was this conversation with
contractors I'm in Baghdad it's 2003
2004 and there's contractors that show
up in Baghdad leak these guys are
Blackwater guys or whatever
triple-canopy guys and these guys come
in to our compound and they just kind of
arrived in country and a couple of them
are former seals you know probably in
the 90s no combat experience and they're
talking to us and you know we're looking
at their gear and we're kind of giving
them a heads up and that Daryl
cuz he's good like this we were asking
the guys because they were they were
about to go to Fallujah and they were
taking up armored at Ford Explorers
which sounds badass but the up armored
Ford Explorers were actually horrible
all they were was a regular Ford
Explorer two-wheel drive Ford Explorer
with like a little bulletproof glass
mounted inside of it they didn't make
any adjustments to the suspension they
didn't make any adjustments to the power
it was just they were junk and so we're
looking at these guys
getting ready to go in Fallujah and
we're asking them hey do you guys have
run flats for year okay we're asking hey
do you have this do you have this do you
have a radio do you have this and then
it's like hey do you have run flats for
your for your Ford Explorers and they're
like no and and Daryl named the podcasts
you know do you have run flats it's such
a great name because that really shows
you where we were at that was towards
the end of my deployment and these guys
are just showing up and Yuri we knew how
bad things could get and how quickly
they could get bad and these guys who
had just showed up had no idea what they
were getting into and within a month the
contractors that got that got ambushed
in Fallujah and strung up on the on the
bridge that were there so we go into all
kinds of things like that type of story
like that type of information which I
really haven't talked about in that
podcast the thread and we're gonna where
we got China coming up we're going deep
on China and so we also have the
grounded podcast which is about
jiu-jitsu we have the warrior kick
podcast which is for our warrior kids
latest latest episode I think it's the
latest episodes about Johnny Kim yeah
Johnny Kim's on it yes guest starring
astronaut doctor and seal Johnny Kim
warrior kids hope don't forget about
that it's available on Jocko store now
is it are we there yet
yes that was a massive hesitation or
your kids help get some killer soap for
yourself and that way you your family
everyone you know can stay clean you can
staying clean we have a YouTube channel
very clean YouTube channel oh we're
actually I'm not sure how clean that
YouTube channel is why can't you just go
in and do like you need to make channels
within the channel one that says you
know whatever you call hype videos or
whatever
well enhanced video you should have
enhanced videos you should have excerpts
you should have the thread you should
have ground it you should have grounded
all in separate channels that's my
humble opinion
know what hope I'll go home and do it
yeah all right taking action well they
are there in playlists right so it's
called place okay they're called so
you've done that already I've done that
but here's the thing what you're talking
about which I agree is it I've done that
or is it here's the thing which one of
these two are we talking about it's
actually technically both so that is
done they're in playlists so you can go
to the playlist section then they'll be
organized but if you go to the main
YouTube then there's a way to organize
it where it displays your playlists with
which is what I think anyway that you're
you're talking about right like channels
within the channel yeah so when you go
to the main page yeah it's like you can
nonetheless yeah it is done so yes they
can be played in a row in order whatever
and you know be not filtered out but
like if you just want to listen to the
thread right and you just let them play
boom see you're saying track yeah got a
more anyway yes you do have a youtube
channel jockle podcast YouTube channel
video version video see what Dave looks
like see what we all look like whatever
also excerpts on there we got
psychological warfare if you need a
little psychological hitter to push you
through a moment of weakness you can
check that out wherever mp3 are sold
wherever mp3 let's go say songs but
they're not songs
wherever mp3 audio is coming at you
check it out psychological warfare is
the name of that flipside campus.com
Dakota Meyer making psychological
warfare for your eyeballs you go to
flipside canvas comm books we got some
books what book
how about the code the evaluations the
protocol Dave Burke how's it going it's
going pretty good
how are you happy with the product I am
I've been more happy with the
interaction that the product has created
yeah interaction man it is so awesome to
see how many people got it and got
either back on the path or understood
the path better the interaction from
that has been awesome and I'm stoked to
be a part of that that is the that book
is like this is another thing that it
that it sort of does and whether it is
this surprising maybe maybe not but it's
like okay so you read it
you could refer to it all this stuff
it's like a big part of it is just a
reminder to just evaluate how good
you're doing and and really remember
that you have you do have a goal right
and if you don't then make it cool
whatever so like this is what it'll do
like if I'll work out which is the
normal thing you know trying to work out
but I'm mentally conscious of like okay
what kind of workout was that was that a
- was that a five you know and I'm
caught like at the end I have a straight
up number done straight up and then I'll
like share it with somebody just threw
up a for today you know whoever you know
if they're sort of in the game as well
like that's what it'll do you know so
it'll keep you on track man in that way
dude without a diet you start thinking
about things you've never thought about
before you yeah also just being able to
say I just need to at least get a 1 over
here just at least like hey and you also
look at some cookies and you say no I'm
not gonna go to zero
Nathan was telling me he had a little
scenario unfold and he was like this
could be a zero zero of a diet I had a
little scenario yesterday just had to
throw up a zero on food on coffee fuel
intake yeah what chocolate you know no
worse way worse doughnut no no I'm never
going to eat doughnuts a day if you see
me eating doughnuts you can stab me in
the face because I just not gonna do it
but mm-hmm
just straight-up American bacon
cheeseburger yeah which right we're
already not good but fries with it
no fat that's just unset yes unset at
the end of the day that does what is
that the that amounts to a zero yeah for
all that's I was actually I asked late I
was like maybe I should have put some
kind of negative numbering like yeah
that's gonna actually take you time to
beg our - yeah right you had a bacon
double cheeseburger the carry over for
the next day is that you're carrying
that weight point tomorrow's no should
even if I ate today you know a grass-fed
steak I you know whatever and and of
salad I would still not even be able to
dig out of the hole no french fries I
don't need french fry come on what's up
what would be a one as far as the meal
goes I think just don't know I think I
think well I don't know because look if
there's if there's a potential for a
five a meal that's a 5 a 4 a 3 a 2 in a
while right it's a whole day you don't
get up have a ideal breakfast and give
yourself a 5 for diet for the day and
call it good you gotta do the whole day
and you know if you're on a 5-4 a diet
that diet is that consumption is
tethered to other things that you're
doing you're an optimize a one is like I
didn't do anything bad yeah I didn't do
anything like constructive either I'm
not like managing what I'm in taking a
ones like you eight to survive you and
you didn't do anything that took you
going backwards but like was involved no
if you are french fries in the day
you're not getting a one okay you know
one is this a one day will say breakfast
lunch and dinner keep it simple okay the
breakfast we ate frosted mini-wheats
know many weeks right now what about
shredding no brother
what no wheat no whole wheat nut cereal
what about granola
oh here's the other thing we got a look
at what is what is it that you've set up
for yourself right because some people
if you're running a marathon all of a
sudden you're gonna need certain foods
that you would not need had you've been
trying to cut weight or had you been
trying to gain weight right it depends
listen there's a thing here that's a
larger net we've had a lot of question
about this first of all
whoever's let you mark yourself whatever
you want this is your evaluation if
you're a habit if you're if you're
someone who spent the last ten years and
you get up in the morning and your
breakfast is doughnuts like that's just
been your thing doughnuts and coffee and
you get off the doughnut and coffee
and you get up and you have some sort of
whole wheat cereal thing to replace that
you you're doing you're improving you're
getting better now is that a five you
know that's not a five and it's not to
like punish you for making one small
mistake but it's the measurement of are
the things that you're doing probably
the biggest takeaways what you said is
are you thinking about this because the
donuts as part of your diet every that
that's your your zero for nutrition in
your life and you need to get on a path
by which that is no longer part of your
repertoire and when you don't do that
you got to account for that you know
what why even play around I have the
book right here here's the deal here's a
score of one four at the end of the day
you ate everything you're gonna eat
here's the score of one food intake was
effective to sustain health but did not
optimize nutrition or participate in
health enhancing program so maybe you
had some little granola like it
sustained you but it didn't optimize
right yeah you weren't recovering from
the we score zero is did not eat
properly and did not provide any
nutritional benefit to perform critical
daily tasks
that's your doughnuts doughnut and a
pizza right you're just to Gary getting
a zero yeah five consumed ideal ideal
food intake and maintained perfect
adherence to diet or fasting every
calorie was optimal what every calorie
was optimal and nothing was consumed
that didn't contribute to health or
nutrition allowing for a sustained peak
level of performance throughout the
entire day yeah no big deal no big deal
I had an interesting situation and throw
it to the crowd here happened to me on
Saturday night so normal day Saturday
we're out it's a good day took my kids
mountain biking made a good day came
back had a good I think I grilled we had
a normal dinner and then we had a little
adult a little situation at the
neighbors we had some we went to the
neighbor's house we did some social
distancing hanging out everything was
cool they're all drinking
I don't drink I'm hanging out it's all
good we had a good time get home just
perform midnight feeling hungry Dave
feeling so at
literally the stroke of midnight I am
consuming strawberry milk at midnight
yeah I'm good with that
yeah I'm told yeah oh yeah my last meal
is way after I didn't need him I should
have just guy didn't need a meal but I
was I wanted something that tasted good
so bad that I just that's a good
question right there one of the good
things about mole yeah check it out you
might feel guilty because it tasted so
good but you're actually good this
cannot be good for me at midnight yeah
and the motive to record you weren't
like hey I'm on this program this smoke
means to facilitate the program you're
like hey I need something that tastes
good there's the milk so it's kind of a
question is that so what is that it's
not like a - it has to be something
because Moke is good for you are you if
you're working out on any regular basis
Moke is good for you and it does support
your goals per se it's good for you
period I don't even think this is a
question actually yeah this is a
positive it's a little guilt because it
tastes so good yeah leadership strategy
and tactics or the code you can get that
one it's up and running we had a little
lag time I apologize I didn't realize
that every single person was gonna buy
it immediately we're back up to speed
sorry about the delay we also have
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual we have where the warrior kid one
two and three we have my key in the
Dragons we have discipline equals
freedom Field Manual we have extreme
ownership and the dichotomy a leadership
we also have a salon front which is our
leadership consultancy where we solve
problems through leadership go to
national on front comm for details a lot
of that right now is taking place on EF
online you heard me reference it a bunch
today go to EF online.com if you want to
interact with us check it out
we're on there we're live not just me
but all the instructors of national on
front different times a day different
subjects lots of interaction QA
leadership primer we talked about that
immediate action drills all kinds of
stuff going on EF online comm check that
out muster 2020 orlando's cancelled
phoenix arizona is up next
16th and 17th and in Dallas Texas
December 3rd and 4th check extreme
ownership calm if you want to come we
cancel an entire muster with 900 people
some of those people are going to
Phoenix and or Dallas so those are gonna
sell out earlier than we thought
get on earlier if you want to go and of
course we have EFI overwatch and EF
Legion if you were in the military go to
EF Legion dot-com and enroll there's
companies that are hiring right now even
though there's companies that are laying
people off and furloughing there are
other companies that are exploding in
growth and need people so go to EF
overwatch and EF Legion EF Legion is
where you can just enroll immediately EF
overwatch is a for companies that are
searching for executive position EF
Legion looking for frontline leaders
frontline managers to make things happen
also America's mighty mighty warriors
dot org this is Mark Lee's mom's charity
organization helping service members
worldwide go to America's mighty
warriors dot org donate you can donate
right there there's a little section
that says donate and she spreads the
love to service members their families
and gold star families and if you
haven't had enough of my oppressive
allocution or echos farcical blathering
or Dave's top gun talk then you can
locate us on the interwebs as well as
Twitter on Instagram and on the face
Dave is that David our Burke echo is at
Echo Charles and I am at Daka willing
and to all the men and women out there
in uniform our military members who
fight and risk it all for our way of
life thank you to the police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Border
Patrol
Secret Service thank you all for taking
care of us here on the homefront and to
all the doctors nurses and medical
personnel that are working to keep us
safe and healthy thank you for
dedicating your life's work to the care
of others and to everyone else out there
remember that you are your own commander
you are in charge of your life you are
the general and you are also the soldier
you have to lead but you also have to
follow that is how you achieve your
mission so go out there then get after
it and until next time this is Dave and
echo and Jocko out